hey what's up guys my name is aeno and
welcome to let's make Flappy Bird so
this is going to be a very long video
probably around 2 to 3 hours in which
I'm going to make Flappy Bird from
scratch essentially not really from
scratch but as in I'm not going to make
a computer first but from scratch using
openg and lwl 3 in Java okay so
essentially we're going to be making the
game for desktop like a full kind of
screen Flappy Bird experience um I'm
going to be doing the whole thing from
start to finish in this one video so at
the end of this video we will have made
Flappy Bird um I'm going to be doing it
all live there's going to be like no
editing at all so you're going to see me
hopefully not fail too much um and
overall it should be a great experience
so since we're kind of doing this from
the beginning um here's Eclipse which is
what the first thing you're going to
want to grab this is uh Luna and it's
4.4.1 in case you wanted the exact same
one I'm using you can get that using the
link in the description below so it'll
be um like eclipse.org whatever anyway
um sa the link in the description below
um and this is the ID we're going to be
using to write all of our code and test
it and debug it and everything so that
in mind when you first open a Clips
you'll be asked to choose a workspace so
that's basically just going to be like a
little um collection it's like a
directory on your hard drive which is
filled with different projects um so
pick a folder where you'd like to store
your project essentially and then you'll
be graded with this you want to click
the
workbench um button and then here we go
here's a clipse so the first thing
you're going to want to do is probably
rearrange this a bit set it up how you
like it this is how I like it you don't
have to do this but you can under window
Show view I'm actually going to bring up
the Navigator and then we're basically
set up here okay so one of the things I
want to mention before we start this
video is I will be trying to explain as
much as possible but the reality of the
situation is I want this to be one video
and I don't have 10 hours so I'm
probably going to roughly explain things
and type as fast as I possibly can to
get this done in a reasonable amount of
time that being said um if there's
anything you don't understand or
something leave a comment below I'm sure
other people including myself will
probably help you out the other thing is
that's really important is if you want
to stay up to date with what I'm doing
and certain events because I don't want
to keep posting an update video every
week updating you on what's going to
happen um that would be silly so instead
I've got a Twitter account which is just
amazingly useful for something like this
so follow me on Twitter it'll be
twitter.com The Cho again Link in the
description and that's probably the best
way to stay up to date hands down all
right anyway let's get into this so the
first thing you're actually going to
want is um lwjgl all right enter lwjgl
so lwjgl or lightweight Java game
library is um is an amazing thing um
it's basically a as this will probably
explain to you it's basically an openg
um binding I would say for Java so
essentially opengl is a graphics kind of
specification written in C essentially
it's actually implemented it's it's open
gel is essentially a specification right
it's not actually a library that you can
download it's something that is written
by uh specifically and implemented by
your actual GPU manufacturers right whe
so whether that be Nvidia ATI Intel all
those companies they are the companies
who actually Implement opengl into their
own cards and their drivers okay that is
the version of open gel you're using
it's depending on on your driver which
is why there are going to be very small
differences between um ATI and Nvidia
graphics cards for example in opengl
applications um the thing is though
openg is actually a set of Standards
obviously in specifications so that it's
not too much different so essentially it
should basically look the same but of
course it doesn't always it doesn't
always but it should so that's the first
thing you need to understand open gel
isn't actually code that you download
it's a specification that is actually
implemented in your graphics card
drivers that being said um you're going
to want to download it so hit
download uh now release isn't actually
out yet we're going to be using lwl 3 by
the way uh so just click on Stable
download that at this at the time of
recording this video this wasn't out yet
I mean it might be when you watch this
but anyway that's the the the gist of
things and under getting started is
basically code that we're about to copy
um not really copy but I'm going to type
a lot of this I actually haven't really
used lwjgl3 too much before so I've used
two and whatnot but not three so I
actually don't know how this works
exactly but we'll figure it out live
because that's how we do things and
hopefully it won't take too long so that
being said a lot of things out of the
way here let's go ahead and go file new
uh Java project so yeah being to finish
off my opengl thing um it is essentially
written in see but the problem is we
can't we're using Java so
lwjgl is basically an interface that
lets us communicate with that c code and
run it so when we call openg methods
we're actually calling native code so
say like C code essentially okay we're
not this isn't like so what I'm saying
is openg GL and Java is the same as open
and C or C++ because there is only one
openg G this is just a binding for it so
that Java can access and run it okay
that's the first thing you need to
understand so let's make let's call the
project Flappy um I'm just going to if I
can type um I'm just going to go ahead
and say 1.8 we're actually running as
you can see that version of java let's
hit finish and here is our project
fantastic so under Source we're going to
go right click new class so we're going
to put it into a package called com. the
cho. Flappy so this is essentially a
folder hierarchy that you set up the
dots are like slashes so these will be
separate folders com then the Cho then
Flappy usually the just the convention
is like your domain name in reverse
order followed by the name of the
project um it doesn't matter what you
put here it'll just create a bunch of
folders on your hard drive okay so
sometimes this is this is necessary and
should be unique for things like I don't
know if you do something for like the
Google Play Store other examples it's
like a namespace kind of thing but not
really anyway once you do that let's
head up uh we'll call our main file main
okay the reason I call that is because
it has a main method which we will
conveniently tick here so we don't have
to type it and hit finish and we should
sa this stuff let me quickly set a few
things up so under window preferences
under General I'm going to quickly
increase the font size of both the
console font and this probably just like
12 or something I don't like it too big
um just so you guys can see it a a bit
better you don't have to do this for
yourselves obviously but since I'm nice
I'll do that there we go so that's
looking better so the first thing I'm
going to do is actually um create two
variables so we're going to have a
private int width equals we go 1280 and
then height
equals um 720 so these are going to be
two uh variables that we create uh which
essentially sore the width and height of
our window in pixels okay great
referring to that getting started guide
do actually get started so the first
thing we should do before we actually do
anything is probably include El uh ELO
jgl into our actual project so to do
that right click on the
um folder here hit
properties and then under Java build
path under libraries this is what we
include right any external jav files or
anything we need to include so to do
that you're going to want to navigate to
wherever your lwjgl extracted files are
from the archive that you downloaded
you'll see a bunch of stuff here all of
it's pretty much important so under jar
there's just one jar file lwjgl jar this
is what we want to actually include so
if we copy this path and then hit add
external jars we can navigate to us
already there there fantastic and then
L.J and just hit open and there it is it
should be here so under native Library
location this is very important as I
just mentioned we're dealing with native
code okay this is just a binding for it
so we need to point Java to where that
native code actually lies okay so uh
under what you'll see under native and
your platform so we're on windows so
under Windows um and then under our so I
would have thought this would be a
32-bit application but it's actually it
actually wants a 64-bit DL so make sure
if you're on 64-bit Windows you actually
include x64 you'll see a bunch of dll
file so open Al that's for audio we
don't really we're not really too
interested in that but we it's in the
folder we'll keep it here we won't
delete it um and then here is a dll file
which is essentially a compiled Library
which is lwjgl or its native code okay
so we want to basically put this folder
under the Java kind of look at this Java
this these are act these are the actual
native stuff that you are interested in
let me just check that I'm recording
because that would be hilarious okay we
are good um I really hope nothing goes
wrong in this video by the way like the
audio doesn't got out cuz this is a
really long video and I don't want to
re-record it a thousand times so under
native Library location hit edit and
then we'll just paste in this thing this
is the folder right so to copy that I've
literally just clicked on the uh the
breadcrumb bar here and copi that and
pasted it in that's it okay great
fantastic because adding hitting
external work folder will just take
forever to navigate to it okay good
we've got that now one thing I I'm going
to do is attach the source we do want
the Java doc but what we're going to do
instead is just attach Source because
the source actually includes Java doc so
again what you'll see under lwjgl three
is a source. zip so that's what we want
so if we copy the path of this folder
again uh double click on Source
attachment and then an external location
paste that in back SL source. zip hit
okay we should have our source attached
so this is the source code for lwjgl
which is important because it contains
Java Dock and I can just see how things
work along the way so if I need to if
I'm not sure cuz again I haven't really
used this too much so if I don't know
how something works I can take a look at
it anyway fantastic lots of talking
let's actually start coding now so
public void run is really what I'm going
to start off with and a public void
start so when our game starts we're
going to create a new instance of our
main class just one of course and then
just hit start we don't even have to
store that instance as an object I'm
just going to go ahead and call start
straight away because that's really all
we want to do we just want to call this
start method now now that we've done
that we probably want to create a new
thread for ourselves so a new thread is
essentially so threads are just ways of
doing stuff concurrently usually code
executes line by line with multiple
threads you can ex execute multiple
lines of code parallel right
simultaneously at the same time so the
reason I'm doing this though and I will
call this
our um I will call this our game
thread um you know sometimes you might
have various threads so first of all if
we're creating a new thread and we're
passing in this as the object obviously
you can see it needs to take in a
runnable so um we we can basically let
main Implement runnable because what
it's all all that's going on right and
the reason we need this is essentially
it wants a call back right essentially
it wants a um a function to run okay so
what we do is when we call thread. Start
Right This Thread will actually execute
it will run this run method on this new
thread okay so in order for it to
basically know that we've got a run
method it needs to it needs to implement
runnable and you can see that let me
quickly just attach Java source as well
um which should be uh where are we Java
JRE that's not what I'm interested in
jdk Source okay you can see that the
runnable interface only has the run
method that's it so um basically forces
us to implement run and when we hit
thread. start this will run on the new
thread that's essentially everything
that's going on here pretty cool so that
being said we
might like just regarding threads as I
make this bullying called Running uh
just regarding threads quickly
um
uh essentially you want to have your you
have you have to have all of your
rendering on one thread in the sense of
when when you create an open Gil context
it's tied to a thread so all of your
open G calls have to be on that thread
so that's why it's quite a common
practice to create two threads one for
the game logic and any kind of game side
stuff and then a rendering thread which
is going to call all the open jail stuff
we're not going to bother with that
because this is Flappy Bird and this is
a really simple or should be a really
simple game to make okay so we're not
going to waste time with all that but
I'm just saying that that could be a
common practice it is a common practice
so in our um in our run method we have
our while running Loop okay which calls
two things update and
render um so I'll make a public void
update these should probably be private
priv
but
um well I guess we should probably make
them private
actually uh no one else should be
calling these except for the except for
this um and this is essentially our main
game Loop so as long as the game is
running it will continue to update the
game and render the game we will do
update significantly slower than
rendering in the future so I like to
leave rendering uncapped just so we can
see performance and whatnot but update
um will be kept to 60 to ensure that our
logic 60 per second that is to ensure
that our logic is the same we could also
be working out things like Delta time
I'm not going to deal with that too much
uh because this will run significantly
fast on pretty much any computer I would
imagine there's not too many things to
there's not too many crazy things going
on in this game it's freaking flappy
birds so yes um init init is going to be
responsible for initializing all of our
stuff now remember everything that
happens in run happens on this new
thread so you cannot initialize openg on
on our standard thread right by is
making the Constructor for example for
Main and doing open gel stuff there we
can't because we have to do everything
within this thread okay in it in it open
essentially and render have to be on the
same thread so make sure that's the case
otherwise you'll run into problems
guaranteed okay so now it's time to
actually use uh glfw so glfw is um a
nice little open
G like window Library thing um for C and
C++ but uh ll3 has decided to
essentially um make a binding to it in
Java so luckily I have used I have used
gfw before quite a bit on um in
C++ so this shouldn't be too difficult
um but essentially what we want to do is
in a it we want to call gfw in it now at
the current moment we have to call gfw
glfw in it now I'm just not a fan of how
that looks okay because we know it's gfw
even this has the prefix so I'm actually
going to get rid of this so to do that
um notice this is a static method as
well right static what that means is
there's only one of it in the class and
because there's only one of it because
it's instant in because it's instance
independent we can just go import static
which will import everything this thing
means everything right it'll import
every static method in the glfw class
and we now no longer have to call glfw
in front of it we can just call that
okay we'll be doing the same thing with
open gel it's just makes everything look
a lot cleaner again you don't have to
but I would recommend you do so we
should probably say if it doesn't
initialize correctly um that's not
actually the correct way of doing it I
think it's something like equals uh GL
like false or something hopefully that's
roughly correct um let me just check
this uh yes so if it if that doesn't
work or if it doesn't equal true I don't
know you can write it either
way then we should probably handle it um
over here but we'll do that later
because we don't really need to do that
now so uh again right we don't want to
have to write gl1 or gl11 in front of it
right so we'll just import
static and there you go fantastic so
that being said let's actually create
our window so what we want to do here is
um we probably want to set a few window
hints so glfw window hint um so these
are kind of like parameters essentially
that we're setting we're hinting J on
how to actually create our window so
we're actually going to set resizable I
don't actually know if this stuff is set
by default or whatnot again I haven't
really used um this too much but I
assume this is we'll just set it
resizable true and then uh visible it'll
be visible it should be visible false by
default okay cool let's create a window
so private Long window so you might be
asking why is this a long why is it not
some kind of window object why is it a
long this is an this is an identifier as
you probably we know glfw is written in
C what that means is there are no there
are no such thing as objects so instead
we use kind of IDs essentially so glfw
create
window um and this should be window
equals GW create window so we'll be
creating it based on the width and
height of course we'll have a title
which I'll just call Flappy for now um
Monitor and share will both be null okay
so these nulls are actually stored
in um inul static all uh
lwjgl do system
do like memory or
something memory util all right and
that's where these ns are at right
they're just over here and they equal
zero so you could have also wrote zero
um Okay cool so essentially this will
kind of return a pointer to like so to
speak um to or like a memory address of
this window it's essentially an ID
though so it'll I don't know how it
works internally um it's probably not a
memory address or so but it will it is
an it is an identifier for this window
so it identifies this unique window and
every time we want to do something like
I don't know set the window position for
example again we pass in the window that
we want to set the position for followed
by the actual position so in in O it
would look something like window. set
position X POS y POS according to that
right but if we don't have objects we do
it this way okay so it's it's not too
different um and it should be fine and
again that's just because gfw is a C
library all right fantastic so that
being said um let's set our window
position so what we want to do is we
want to set it to um be the center so to
do that we actually have to get the
current
um vid mode which is gfw get video mode
um gfw get primary monitor so we're
getting the primary monitor which is
your primary Mones uh like
characteristics essentially such as the
real one we're interested in is
resolution really so X position y
position is all that's going to be is um
essentially gfw vid vid mode um do width
so we're getting the width of this vid
mode of this one right so our current
characteristics we're going to get the
width of it we're going to subtract our
width from it and divide everything by
two we should get us into the center
okay so we're going to do the same thing
for height of
course and we are not going too quickly
I should probably start talking less and
coding more cuz otherwise this will take
4 hours which is not good um okay great
so again we could probably say something
such as if window equals null uh again
I'm going to just put as whoo for
now so we probably want to print
something I'll return as well I should
do that here as well so that we don't
crash um but yeah so this is if window
equals not uh and um
this should be well in equals zero or
null um okay great so there we go
um we got that stuff done and this
should obviously happen straight after
we create our window and everything else
looks pretty pretty sweet so we also
want to make the context
current uh
glfw what is it JW make context current
it's just not our current thing
window uh so where where would that be
that would be
in I don't know that should be in in
here but it's not
apparently okay so this I've at one
point hit control shift o and it's
reorganized everything and gotten rid of
my uh star so to fix this and so it
doesn't do this so it doesn't
automatically get rid of our or
reorganize our inputs our Imports again
if we go to window and then preferences
what you'll see under Java and and then
code style and then organize Imports is
number of static Imports needed for the
star uh 99 so we'll change that to one
and what that will do is control shift o
it'll prefer the star for static stuff
which is essentially what we want okay
fantastic so um now that we've got that
back um let's go ahead and show the
window after we make it so we'll show it
now we can enable vsync as well by
changing the swap interval we'll do that
later though I don't like vsync straight
away because I like to measure our
performance um in an easy way so we'll
keep this as is for now okay great let's
quickly um just write some more code to
make sure this works so if in our random
method we want to update stuff so I
think it's just um gfw swap buffers yeah
so swap buffers for our window of course
um oh whoops accidentally closed
that uh and in update we want to pull
our events so this will do like key
events which we're about to implement
Okay cool so this uh while running Loop
though what we want to do is we want to
say um in our Loop that if essentially
if GL of w window should
close
window um so if this
equals GL true then we just simply set
running uh equal to false
all right simple as that so if we now
run this let's see what we get okay so
we get a screen and it closes instantly
cool so let's fix that up um something's
wrong essentially uh it did show our
thing for a minute so thread Out start
okay so we probably want to set running
to true and not false I don't know why
that was false but if we if we run this
again we should see a black window
called Flappy with our stuff and if we
close this it'll it should close the
window okay great fantastic so where
we've got something now and we can
probably uh accelerate the speed at
which we make Flappy Bird now so let's
quickly Implement input and callback
stuff so under Flappy I want to make a
new class not interface class not
interface class called input which will
really be just keyboard I think uh I'll
put this into the input package as well
just for LS
um okay so this is going to um Implement
uh something
called um
uh what is it called
glfw come on give me something no
proposals uh
glfw uh key call back I
believe
no no no
um this is in gel is this defined in gfw
or something jell W call back it is
somewhere in here believe me ah my
goodness okay
so oh it's a class okay my bad so
extends uh JW key call back so it's
probably an abstract class yes okay um
so we'll import that and we'll import
we'll include any unimplemented methods
which really invoke so long window in
key scan code so um this likes to be
tricky so key is actually our key code
scan code is not what we're looking for
so we want key because the key code
corresponds with uh our actual Keys
which aren't even written here but
um I would have thought it'd be here but
no I don't know where the keys they're
probably just in
jell yeah here we go so these Keys these
key codes actually correspond with this
key not the scan code so that can be a
bit of a curveball so just keep that in
mind we're going to make a public static
bullying array called keys which will be
set to new bullying um I'll just set it
to the default uh I'll set it to the
highest value that an
unsigned um character can represent just
because we can't possibly have anything
any key codes higher than that um that
could be a lot of memory being allocated
but whatever that's not really that much
um a bullion's only one bu it anyway it
should be okay cool
so now that that is done um when we do
invoke something right what we want to
do is we want to check the so window we
don't really care about that we've only
got one window anyway so under action
right we want to say that basically um
keys at index key right if we're going
to set it conditionally equal to
something so if action is equal to gfw
do
gfw um release then we set uh this to
false right otherwise um we essentially
will set it to true
so we're kind of doing something like
that right obviously we can rewrite this
as if action so action doesn't equal G
release now the reason I haven't done it
something like action equals press is
because there's actually one more event
there's release there's press and then
there's repeat so that's when when you
start repeating characters um so if you
hold something down essentially so
that's why we're doing it this way okay
it's very important that you do it this
way so um so if it doesn't because
release is the only event that fires
when we release so we set it equal to
false if that's the case otherwise we
set it true all right fantastic so this
is static because we really only need
one of them um why because we've only
got one window that we really care about
anyway so there we go done we need to
set this call back obviously so to do
that um we need
to uh call once the window has been
created I'll just call it over here glfw
set key call back so window and then the
call back which is of course our uh we
can just go new input so the thing is um
Java has no concept of function pointers
it's got kind of similar things called
lambdas and Java rate but for the most
part there is no way to point to a
function so we can't really have
callbacks instead we have to create
entire classes that contain functions
such as invoke instead of just being
able to pass a function that was in here
so input we could have probably created
in the main class to be honest we didn't
have to make a new file for it I did
just for organization purposes but again
you can you don't have to make a new
file for this you just need to wrap your
invoke method in a class which extends
call back which has an
abstract um void called invoke okay
there we go so that's how Stuff handled
let's just make sure this works so in
update um after we pull events I'm going
to go ahead and say
if input
dot uh if input. Keys uh um and we'll
say so J W key let's just say space cuz
I think we'll use a space bar probably
for flapping the bird so if that um is
true we'll print out a nice message like
flap or yeah flap so if we run this and
we hit space
bar as long as it's down we should get
flap all right fantastic good so our
keys are working awesome we're making
progress slowly very slowly let's get
into uh some so let's just make sure
openl is actually working so what I'll
do is I'll quickly um in open G now I'll
set GL clear color to be uh we'll just
say
white okay and um I'll
also
uh so we'll we'll enable we'll go ahead
and enable depth test we'll need that
anyway um and we'll go ahead and say
we'll print out so we'll say open GL and
then we'll print out the current GL
version so GL get string G version all
right and then over here when we render
before we sell the buffers I'll call G
Clear
G color buff a
bit which will be enough for now all
right okay so we crashed that's fun uh
illegal State exception so there is no
open jail contacts so I assumed there
was so this is interesting uh ja make
contacts current oh there's one there's
one thing we have to actually do first
we actually have to register um we
actually have to register uh the context
with LJ so if we call GL context do
create from current it will actually so
we've created the context in glfw now we
have to tell L wgh yell that okay the
context exists so if we run this now we
should see a no it's still being a
bastard so let's figure this out so we
actually have to obviously do this
before we call open jail methods
otherwise it will not do anything okay
and Java just Fallen crashed okay cool
let's start that again there we go white
cool done and just to prove it if I
change this to zero we should get pink
so let's just run that pink yay okay
there we go so it is now working uh
correctly fantastic so let's also clear
the uh depth
um buffer bit cuz we'll need that I
don't think we'll need that too much
though we are dealing with kind of 2D we
will have yeah we might as well do we
should probably do that anyway okay cool
so I'll get rid of that flap thing um
and now we can probably start with
actually
uh with actually making flabby bird so
let's go ahead and get some of the we
basically just going to spend most of
this time making utility classes because
that's what we need to actually draw
graphics and stuff so I'm going to start
off with maths because that's just the I
don't know boring thing I guess perhaps
so I'm going to make a class called
Vector
3F so this Vector 3F class
um is essentially going to contain all
of
our uh Vector operations so we only
really need 3F so the reason we have 3F
and you might be thinking this is a
three component Vector we're dealing
with a 2d game why is this the case um
is
because is because um we so the Zed
component will be the render order right
so we are doing depth test which means
we are actually checking for which
pixels are in front of other pixels so
what we do is we say based on the Z
value that's the render order so if we
put a bird at a low at a higher Zed
value than something else it'll be in
front of that object okay so the bird
the bird Zed might be like one
or5 and the background might be at .5 or
something um and that way the background
will be behind the bird okay which is
irrespective of which order we actually
call the rendering in which is very
important
sneeze another sneeze okay anyway is out
of the way uh
let's um set everything to zero it will
be Zero by default I know I'm just
setting this anyway just so that we can
see what it's doing for those of you who
don't understand um so Vector 3F so
another Constructor this will take in
flo XY
z uh and this will set this x equal
x this do yal y this zal Z fantastic
there we go so um that is done now we
could Implement a variety of uh Vector
operations this is not a tutorial on how
to make a math Library we simply don't
need any other Vector operations except
a way to store three floats so that
being said that's it we're done okay um
but yeah we just don't need any any of
that Vector Maths for this series so
what I'm going to do is create a matrix
4f class now now this will actually have
a lot of maths in it um and this will be
not in input this will be in
maths I don't know why I made math and
maths I'll actually get rid of that one
because in Australia we spell maths with
an s on the end cuz we're cool like that
so I'll add that to the backage
Declaration all right so um we're going
to actually store this uh Matrix which
I'll call Elements um as a
4x4 uh array okay so basically it's
going to be a 16 float array you can
store these outside of an array you can
St this as a two-dimensional array you
can install this as an array of vector
4fs we're going to be doing it this way
because just because okay no real reason
so um we'll probably make a ton of
Constructors uh we don't really need to
what I'll do is I'll make
a I'll make a matrix 4f
Constructor um I'll also make a public
static Matrix
4f identity so what this will do is um
essentially create an identity Matrix
and return it create a new identity
Matrix and return it so we'll go ahead
and say Matrix for result equals new
Matrix
forf what we'll do is we'll go through
everything and set it to zero now in
um public float public final float size
equal 4 * 4 just quickly clean this up
um
in Java everything you create as a field
is automatically instantiated SL
initialized so this is really
unnecessary I believe uh why are you why
are you screaming okay yeah this should
be static obviously the size will not
change based on the instance we're at
so um this should be an integer
also uh so yeah so really we don't
really need to go result do elements I
equals z because that's the default
right but the reason I'm put putting
this here is to show it okay in the code
um because yeah okay but just saying you
don't need that at all that'll be it'll
it'll all be Zero by default Okay cool
so now we actually want to diagonally
set it equal to one um again I'm not
going to spend too much explaining maths
here because it will take forever so
what you want to do is watch the flat
the last ma Flappy Bird series um and
you want to watch the math video I'll
link it in the description so go ahead
and watch that if you're interested in
uh why we're doing this and how it all
works because I've got like some nice
animations there and everything that
will actually explain everything to you
okay but we're diagonally creating one
okay so that is an identity Matrix
anything we multiply by this Matrix will
be result so a Time identity Matrix will
equal a okay so it won't change it then
it will return
result Okay so we've got that now um
let's go ahead and create an
orthographic Matrix so an orthographic
Matrix is and we'll get we'll make this
static um an orthographic Matrix is a
type of projection Matrix which
orthographic which um essentially is
usually defined by clipping planes
sometimes it can be defined by weird
things like aspect ratio and field of
view sometimes okay that's more of a
perspective thing there but usually it's
defined by uh six clipping planes right
so essentially we're making a box okay
um and uh it's basically usually used
for 2D rendering it can be used for 3D
rendering of course but the main reason
it's not is because there is no concept
of depth in the sense that we're used to
as humans so things that are further
away things that have a larger Zed value
do not actually decrease in size in an
orthographic projection okay so things
that are further away remain the same
size which is why it looks really weird
um if you're viewing a 3D scene through
an orthographic projection but
um it
is
um it is useful for things like 2D okay
when we just don't need that okay so
this is the orthographic projection
Matrix if you Google this or watch my
maths video you will see what is up and
what I'm doing but essentially I'm just
setting up all this
stuff so this should be near Min as far
this should be top minus
bottom all right and then finally we
need so the reason we we all need this
is for our shaders essentially to know
what they're doing so if I didn't
mention what using modern open gel of
course not legacy so that's why we need
all this the other thing I should
mention is that um what we're looking at
uh essentially is um or at least this
Matrix is actually in column major
ordering which means that this is the
actual
uh what am I saying this is
um let's see I always forget this no so
so this is the row that we're at so this
is kind of the it's the row okay and
then this is the column okay so this is
the third column 012 which will be going
down okay that's the order that that's
the order that this Matrix is defined
out so this is not the column right this
is the row and then this is the column
okay so again if you watch the maass
video you will
see um left minus
right and I would recommend you do watch
that because it is uh very
useful and it is basic basically
mandatory to know how this works um well
to an extent otherwise you will have
trouble math is very important for game
development as if I don't know who
doesn't know that some universities like
to imply that you don't need math to
become a programmer or a game programmer
but that is absolutely not true so I
don't know why they would say such a
thing so um this should be far minus
near actually so far minus near far Plus
near all right done so now we will
return our result so that's our author
graphic projection I really hope that's
right we'll see when we run it but I
believe that is correct okay we've done
that now next up we need a few different
matrices we need a translation matric so
public static Matrix
forf uh translate so this will translate
this will create a translation matric uh
based on Matrix based on our supplied
Vector so this Vector will be a like
position for example and now we're going
to create a matrix um out of that so
Matrix
forf results so again I think we will
what am I doing uh we will start off
with our identity Matrix because it just
because it's closer to to what we want
than zero everywhere um and then we'll
set our elements in that Matrix so we'll
set a few things so what we want uh
really is 0 plus 3 so on the third
column we would we just want to which is
the last column by the way because zero
was the first one so the fourth column
even though it says three fourth column
um we want to set the top uh the so top
the second one and the third one to um
the components of the vector essentially
then that that is the so one two that is
the um that is essentially uh our
translation matric okay or Matrix one is
Matrix two is matrices two or more is
matrices uh we need a rotation matric
now the cool thing about and again I
said matric the cool thing about this is
we don't actually need since this is 2D
we won't be rotating things kind of
skewy and weird in threedimensional
space so we only need it around the Zed
axis which is kind of 2D rotation so
because of that the code is much simpler
so Matrix for result again we'll start
with identity uh and we'll say so we'll
Define a few things so first of all we
need the um angle which is that but we
need it in r radians so we're going to
call math do 2 radians and then angle
which is our angle in
degrees um I'll also go ahead and
essentially I guess C the
um the angle uh the angles cosine and S
because we'll be using them much times I
don't want to recalculate the same s and
cosine value every time so we'll just
catch them that'll make it a bit faster
um M uh elements not Matrix elements is
Matrix is what I'm thinking my head but
elements is really what it's called 0 +
0 * 4 equals
cosine
um uh 1 + 0 * 4 = sign negative sign and
cosine all right so this obviously
changes though uh this is 1 1 and this
is
01 and that's it again watch the maths
video for more
okay so that's rotate done and then we
need one more okay and our one more
is
um our multiplication
one um I guess Matrix so we want to be
able to multiply matrix by the matrices
um mul uh matrix multiplication is uh
quite different from regular
multiplication I can't see anything on
my keyboard let me just turn the back
light
on there we go so
um what we'll do is we'll say uh result
equals identity I
guess no actually no we'll start with
zero so we'll just make a new Matrix
for um so yeah matrix multiplication is
quite different from regular
multiplication so I would probably
recommend that you do watch the math
video or go to school or something and
um see how it actually works because uh
it's a bit different so that's why we
actually need to do this so basically
each um
column uh to get the each resulting
element in the resulting matric that we
get for the Matrix that we get from the
multiplication you need to multiply uh
the row of the first one by the column
of the second one and then you add the
results of each of those individual
multiplications together to get the um
to get the resulting multiplication so
go ahead and watch the math video
there's like a nice animation there that
shows you exactly how it works so e
stands for element
um which is very uh useful so
sum is going to plus equal so again you
can see that we're doing this so uh we
we're multiplying the current um matric
here by the way so we'll go elements of
the current one um I'll keep this there
just to remind us uh x + e * 4 uh
multiplied by uh this
Matrix um elements so the one that we're
multiplying by which is the right side
of the equation I guess
um as in will be our one times this one
uh e plus y so we multiplying it against
again the
um column of that uh that's it right so
element will be going down the column
and multiplying it against this one
which will be going across the columns
across the rows okay so there we
go and then that'll create the that'll
create the um resulting matri Matrix
matrixes I don't know the resulting
Matrix
um
element okay so there's quite it's quite
there quite
involved um which is why the animation
in my video will help you a lot okay and
this is obviously not this is elements
all right done there we go presso so um
there is our multip we we're basically
done with our maths what we do need
though is a way to actually go from uh
float array to float buffer so the way
we could do that is actually make a two
float buffer method which we'll call
something called buffer UIL which we're
about to invent I know uh there is
actually one in ljl we're not interested
in that one because it's just not what
we need um we'll go create do create
float buffer from our elements so we
will actually create a float buffer from
an array so let's go ahead and import
flow buffer first of all and then we'll
create this buffer utils
class it'll be in Flappy dos which are
all of our utility classes so moving on
to buffer utils what do we want we want
a private Constructor because this is
going to be a static only class and we
don't want people to accidentally um
instantiate it because that would be
wrong uh we'll create three different
types of buffers buy buffers Flo buffers
and int buffers so to create a bite
buffer we take in a bite array obviously
and then what we do is we call bite
buffer result equals bite
buffer uh allocate direct okay so the
capacity that we want is actually in
bytes okay not in elements so that being
said when we are specified length
obviously each element in this is one
bite because it's an array of bytes so
we can just type in the length here but
for the other ones we'll actually have
to probably multiply by something uh now
the order we want is bite order
native order okay and that's all we want
now we're into the result we actually
put in our
array and then we return it now one
thing you do need to do though is
actually flip the array uh to reverse it
CU we want it ready to be streamed
essentially ready to be read okay so
that's our bite buffer uh let's now
create a float
buffer so a float buffer um is a bit
different because floats are not one by
they are four bytes so so in order to
make this work um we take in a float
array uh we do still when we go float
buffer we do still create a bite buffer
okay we just at the end append as float
buffer and then it will change into
float buffer now this all looks
fantastic except for the fact that um
it's not going to create enough so what
we want to do is actually multiply this
by four okay multiplying this by four is
the sh same as shifting it left by two
because that will multiply by two the
power of two okay which which is four so
I'll just use the bit shift cuz I'm cool
like that all right that's the flow
buffer done finally we need the int
buffer so the int
buffer um we'll take in an integer array
uh and otherwise it'll do the same thing
right we just need to obviously change
this to in
buffer um including here all right and
then we'll finally obviously change this
to be as int buffer all right that's it
so this is a pretty basic thing make
sure you're important puffer it's a
pretty basic thing uh and it's just
three little helpers that will help us
out for things like this as you can see
it's now one L code to create that
fantastic done so what we need to do now
is probably set up all of our other
classes so I'm going to do my least
favorite first and that is the Shader
class I absolutely hate setting up
setting up Shader classes because I've
done it so many times and it's I don't
know for some reason it's just annoying
so we'll put this into utils as well um
we'll call it Shader util
okay not Shader Shader utils so the
Shader class actually won't be that bad
now the Shader utils class is a touch
different because this is going to be
responsible for loading in a file and
actually returning essentially an open
gel program ID okay or a Shader ID so
what I'll do is again I'll make a
private Constructor it's a util class
[Music]
um so it doesn't need a it should be all
static so there'll be static in load and
it'll take in a a Vertex array path not
vertex array path a Vertex Shader path
and a fragment Shader path so these are
actual file paths so we'll just go
string ver so this will be the actual
loaded data from the string we'll call
file utils which is a class we're about
to make um to load it as
string then we'll go ver path and we'll
do the same for the frag so F tools.
load string frag path okay and then
we'll create it essentially so let's
create this first though uh again inails
all right so file utils is going to be
very simple it's going to Simply read
a read a um string uh reading a file as
a string so public string load as string
now what we want to do is um load the
file and read it line by line so string
result oh okay what we'll actually use
for this is something called string
Builder now string Builder is is
something that doesn't re doesn't
recreate the string every time we append
to it now the reason we don't want this
by the
way is because um what actually happens
right is strings
are strings are let me quickly just
right so this is going to actually load
it's going to read the file line by line
um and it's going to load in and I just
did a bunch of stuff it's going to load
in
our um by the way if you hit control
shift o it'll import everything for you
automatically that's what I'm doing to
get stuff to import stuff um buffer
reader so this this is going to load our
stuff so what we want to do is we'll
create a string called buffer right now
instead of just simply in our y Loop
where we set buffer equal to reader.
readline and we're saying that as long
as this doesn't equal null because if it
does equal null it means we've reached
the end of the file and there's no more
to read instead of going ahead and being
like result which would have been a
normal string plus equals right what
this will do is actually reallocate the
entire string again because it's a
character array and characters array are
character arrays are constant obviously
we can't change they're not variable
size we can't change it so we have to re
reallocate a whole new character array
to hold the extra characters string
Builder doesn't do that string Builder
basically behind the scenes I'm not sure
what it does it depends on the actual
string builder of course but it will
just essentially allocate a huge buffer
and it won't have to re basically won't
have to re allocate stuff because it's
already allocated a lot and then at the
end it'll just copy down into a normal
string which is what we'll do so it
basically just saves on reallocating so
we use do aenda with that because Java
isn't great with operator overloading of
course um we'll close the reader at the
end okay and then finally we'll just go
return result. two string all right so
the idea is and this is a unique one
that we'll actually um return a new
string based on what what it is so as
you can see it we'll create it based on
the count which is the amount of
characters we have actually gotten there
okay so string Builder is a
very it's it's great for performance and
you should only use it in Loop so don't
use it everywhere because it's it'll be
pointless for things like that all right
um so if we did fail though and run our
file which shouldn't really happen but
if we did fail we'll catch an IO
exception and we'll just probably print
the stack Trace because the only reason
we'll fail if we can't read the file if
the file couldn't be found and blah BL
blah we'll deal with that later done
okay so that's that's a quick
explanation of string Builder uh so make
sure load the string is
static all right and now we got these
things so what we're going to do is
return this is a load method after all
return um create vert and frag so these
shaders right I want to talk a bit about
what shaders are in a men in case you
don't know but um these shaders are um
or these strings I should say are
actually the contents of the Shader file
so it's all the source code for the
Shader so public static int create
um the reason I made this public is in
case for some reason you already have
the Shader as a like in case you don't
want to do files and you just write it
as a string in your program you can call
the create method to create it instead
of load so load will load it from a file
create will create it from the sources
all
right so shaders are basically line or
shaders are basically pieces of code
which run on our um graphics cards okay
so they do things usually concerning
Graphics um and just because it's a lot
faster to run that code on the graphics
card than the CPU essentially and also
so let's quickly import static or also
um essentially you can't do certain
things on the CPU so we can't tell the
graphics card where to render things on
the CPU because it'ses CPU doesn't do
that it's the graphics cards drops so um
what we want here is probably a variety
of version so we really probably want
two which is what introduced shaders so
that'll have stuff like uh open gel 2.0
that is which Inu sh so that'll have
stuff like create program and most of
the stuff we need probably um so the
vert ID will be Gill create
Shader Gill vertex
Shader um yeah so they're basically just
programs which run run on our graphics
card okay and they do they usually do
Graphics related things such as for
example calculating lighting
um uh
you know positioning our vertices
telling the graphics card where to
render certain things and what color to
render those certain things at so it's
it does stuff like that essentially
right so it's we want to be able to
write those programs to tell our game
what to do if we don't the graphics card
receives a bunch of data which is all of
our Graphics data to render and it's
like well what do I do with this data
how do you want me to render it it has
no idea which is why we need to write
shaders and tell it Okay so we've
compiled our Shader now we've compiled
the vertex Shader now that we've done
that we probably check to make sure it
actually succeeded in compiling the
vertex Shader so what we'll say is GL
get Shader I or rather we'll say
if GL get Shader I so the Shader that
we're going to be interested in is our
vertex Shader so vert ID which is the
open G ID for our specifically like
specific vertex Shader we'll check the
compile status now if this equals false
or GL
false which is zero um we'll go ahead
and we'll go system. Arrow line the
Arrow does run on a different thread I
believe and it's it's actually quite
weird but it will print uh in red text
in Eclipse that's like the only reason
I'm using it so fail to compile a Vertex
Shader now apart from just printing that
we should probably print out the actual
compiler error so to do that we need to
um set err print
line Gill G info log uh vert ID and then
of course oh we actually have to specify
a buffer side I don't think so no we
don't otherwise I would have put like 20
48 or something so we've compiled that
let let's now compile out so if that
works let's return
um1 I don't know
um uh and if that did work though
clearly we have compiled our stuff
successfully and we can actually create
we can link those two shaders to create
a program so frag ID frag ID um fil to
compile fragment Shader and frag ID all
right fantastic done so
um we need to attach data to so in this
case we're going to be only using two
shaders right vertex and fragment
shaders there are other shaders such as
geometry or tessellation shaders we're
not interested in them we're making a
very simple game flaffy bird which does
not need freaking tessellation shaders
cuz there's not much things that we can
really tesselate um so we're not going
to bother with that
obviously
okay so program and Jill validate
program
program all right return program
all right great so there we go um that
should be it I
believe um what we should do is once we
do actually attach our shaders and Link
it and validated and everything's like
just beautiful we do actually want to
call delete
Shader um so verid and frag because we
don't long need them they're already
part of the program and everything's
good so let's delete all that stuff just
so that we're fantastic okay great so
now we want to create a Shader class so
this is going to go into uh a little
folder called Graphics which will have
graphical related things so Shader what
this class will do is represent an
actual Shader so I don't want to use
openg calls like I don't want to
actually physically write openg code
every time I want to activate my Shader
I want to class that does that for me
okay so what I'm going to do is make
this Shader class so this again this
will take in um a vertex and a fragment
Shader these are file paths um
it will have a it'll have an
ID um probably a final
ID nice constant one um so it will go
Shadow tools. load uh vertex fragments
right um and everything will be
fantastic so this will actually load all
of our shaders for us St uh shaders will
be um written as static instances
instances of this class I probably yeah
I assume that's probably the best way to
do it actually um and everything will be
fantastic so what we want to do though
is so we've got an ID now we want to add
methods such as enable and disable right
which will essentially as the name
implies uh bind or unbind that program
essentially enable disable that program
so what we'll do is we'll
import static or. lwl do um opengl do
gl20 uh so we'll go GL use program
ID now if ID is negative one this will
actually probably W crash but it'll
cause jail errors so what we could do is
simply say if ID is negative 1 render
this class unusable have a bully and
called something like invalid or
something and then just don't check for
and don't run this we're not going to
deal with that you know
what don't watch this video if you want
to learn how to make really like strong
code basically non penetrable nonre code
because we're interested in making
Flappy Bird here and that is um a
different ball game to making like a
game engine for example so yeah I will
mention things that we could do here and
there but I won't actually do
them okay so G uniform so uniform
variables are essentially ways that we
can actually transmit uh data or I guess
provide our shaders with data from the
CPU okay
so in this case we're setting a single
integ so essentially if we declare an in
in our Shader and we declare as uniform
we can
actually give it some data from our
program from java from our CPU so what
we'll do is we'll say public void um or
public uh int um so I'll just call it
get
uniform so this what this is going to do
is get the uniform of um a certain uh
Shadow right so it'll get the get the
location of a certain Shader so in order
to in order to actually set data we
actually have to find the location of
that variable in our Shader essentially
so what we'll do is we'll say um
essentially it's going to be just as
simple as return get uniform
location uh ID and then the name okay
that's it if that is negative one it
means it couldn't find it okay or yeah
essentially
so G get uniform
location I don't know why I just did
that so we just use get uniform instead
of that and we just type in the name
that's it okay fantastic so the value is
going to be value now a few things that
I want to note quickly which we will
actually probably do is a this returns
negative one so what we want to like it
could so what I do want to do is
actually pin it to a result um and
before we we return it I just want to
check to see if this result actually
equals ne1 because if it does I just
want to print a nice courtesy message
being like um could not find uniform
variable
um and then we'll just print the name
all right so I'll just you know just as
a little courtesy uh say that we
couldn't print it now the other thing I
want to do is actually cage these names
we're going to be running these checks
incredibly often right multiple times
per frame Okay so a big bottleneck uh is
actually the um the communication
between the CPU and the GPU okay so we
don't want it basically it's just it's
very inefficient for us to check the
stuff we already know and actually ask
the GPU what's up and then get the data
back to the CPU it's just going to it's
very inefficient so what we want to do
instead is actually cache these
locations the reality of this situation
is that we will request a location from
a Shader we'll get a response an integer
location as as to where it's actually
located and then that location won't
change for the duration of our program
yet every frame we ask at the location
again and again and again so what we
want to do is only check it the first
time essentially right so what we can do
is create a map right so what we so what
we'll do is we'll create a map of string
being the name and then the integer
being the location we'll call it
location
case we'll set it equal to new hashmap
so this is like one of those
optimization things that I promised I
wouldn't do but I'm doing here just cuz
it's hard to ignore um we'll import all
that stuff again control shift o or
command shift o on Mac we'll do that for
you um and then what we'll do is we'll
we'll we'll check we'll say we'll say if
location case actually contains key
right being the name yeah then we've
already got it so we can just go ahead
and return um location case. getet name
right simple as that because we've
already we've already we've already
discovered the location otherwise we'll
go ahead and do this stuff okay and
we'll say actually we'll say once we
figure out the result um if the result
doesn't equal
ne1
uh yeah we'll say here anyway we'll say
um location case so else I guess we'll
add it into location cache so we'll say
location cache do put key being the name
of course and value being result all
right great so it won't do that we'll
see this in action eventually as well
awesome so we're getting through this I
hope I'm still recording it says I am
drop frame zero cool so it's been an
hour okay so we're an hour in and we've
done this much which I think is
acceptable so I'm going to just take a
quick drink cuz it's very hot
today and hopefully you guys are all
still following along and you're having
fun so
we need to do this for a number of
different things okay not just for one
integer we also want to do this for
stuff like floats and other stuff so one
F first of all again the only thing that
changes is really the fs and whatnot
that's it done um we also want to create
it for two
floats um so we'll just taking float X
and Float y we don't have a vector 2f so
yeah so 2f and then this will be x y
um and then we want to do it for three
floats now for three floats we can
actually take in a vector
3F vector and then simply just go Vector
dox
um Vector doy and vector. z and then set
this to 3F
fantastic so now now that that is done
um and of course we want to change this
to set uniform 3F um we do need to set
our actual matrices right so the things
that we created that actually tell us
important things we want to set them
into our Shader so uh set uniform mat
f m these are always going to be Flo but
anyway um we'll go ahead and we'll say
so string name of course and then Matrix
4f
Matrix and then we'll say G uniform um
Matt Matrix
4f4 alternate version of okay we'll call
4 F maybe I guess I don't know there
shouldn't be a 4 F I don't know what is
up I'm just going to quickly check the
source code how is this different
than specifies the value of yes that is
correct can trans that's all right good
so what's how is this
alternative it doesn't check it or
something okay in the end it calls the
native the same native function value
remaining count
oh I see it's got different parameters
so it doesn't have the count I see okay
so we don't we'll we'll have it figure
it out so we W to use
4f
so okay so location is going to be get
uniform uh name is going yeah of course
name uh transpose false so if we had it
in row major cuz open G wants column
major if we had in row major we could
Chang it through and it would fix it but
or R transpose it but um we've already
got in col matri so we didn't need to
and the value of course is going to be
Matrix do to float buffer or there we
go done that's it that's how we set
matrices okay fantastic
so um cool we actually getting somewhere
now so inside Graphics the next major
thing I want to create so we've got two
more things to create we've got textures
and then we've got vertex arrays and I
think that's pretty much it so in
texture so this is a lot of utility
classes I'm sure you guys are learning
heaps if you've never seen this stuff
before this is basically it's almost
like we're making a mini game engine
well we are I guess to make Flappy Bird
work um okay so private in texture which
is going to be our texture ID okay so
public texture is going to Simply take
in a path being the file path um and
it's going to call a method called
load which is right here public int load
string path okay uh it's going to take
in um it's going to it's actually going
to do a lot of things it's going to um
create an array of pixels first of all
and then feed them to open jail
essentially but we'll be doing
a a lot of reordering of color channels
in a minute as well unfortunately we
have to so um buffet image image equals
image io.
read new file input stream uh
path okay so width and height we're
going to set the width equal to image.
getwidth and and the height equal to
image. get
height all right alls again control
shift to Mac we'll uh do that uh we'll
go ahead and catch an exception if we
need to which we might um okay so pixels
now that we know the width and height we
can instantiate the pixels array so
we'll set it equal to new in width time
height um and then finally we need to
populate the pixels array with the
actual data so zero zero width height
pixels zero width done right pretty
basic stuff so um this is obviously
passed by reference it's an array so
it'll fill that array with the image
data okay fantastic and by image data I
mean the pixels of the image um or the
pixels color values of the image
okay so next up we unfortunately need to
actually rearrange it slightly before we
put it before we give it into openl so
I'll make a new int called data um and
then I'm actually going to make a for
Loop which will go through every
single
um integer or every single Pixel in our
integer
right extract all the channels so pixels
I and this is the alpha channel so we
it'll be
here um
and um so we'll go for all of them of
course
rgba um so R of two get rid of four and
that'll be like that that'll actually we
can I guess we can go zero if we want it
kind of align this which we'll just
multiply by divide by one um but this is
going to be eight and this is going to
be 16 so we've separated all the
channels again if you want to know how
this works watch uh the kind of texture
video I had for let's make flppy bird so
if you there'll be a link to the
description in that that'll tell you all
about all this and what it's actually
doing so we're basically just
rearranging stuff okay so because here
is where the rearranging happens so the
alpha Channel still goes in the same
location as it was okay we just had to
extract it because we needed needed its
data next we have this one next we
have uh the green Channel and finally
we've got the red channel so if we read
this from right to left which is the way
we kind of do read it in a way um
because this is actually going to be the
least significant pixels uh what it used
to be is AR
argb okay or BG that way now what it is
is abgr or rgba okay because Opel
actually wants this order so it actually
reads it in a bit differently you'll see
this in a minute when when actually
physically type it but we'll create the
result here um which will be GL gen
textures now this I believe is in
1.1 um open GL 1.1 that is so
import static um org. lwl
opengl
one I guess yeah it is okay good so
result uh so yeah so we'll go g bind
texture so we need to bind it before we
can use it think of it as selecting a
layer in Photoshop before you actually
make changes to it right you have to
select it first um and to deselect it we
just call the reverse of well we call by
texture with zero and that just
deselects everything okay um we'll
deselect the only one with we've got
selected so this is kind of the
selecting the thing we're selecting and
that's what we're setting it to okay um
so if you're binding a g texture 2D it
will remain bound until you unbind that
texture 2D if you're binding another
texture like a texture 3D or something
um which isn't a thing yet in openg I
think it's in another version of openg
but if you're buying something else
um like ond for example yeah that'll
they're like kind of different channels
so if you buy this and then you buy 2D
you're binding two different things to
two different areas so yeah just keep
that in mind anyway um text parameter so
you can only have one texture 2D bound
at once
right okay uh so gex 2D of course uh the
name we're going so we're going to be
setting a few things we are probably
going to be upscaling our Graphics
slightly as they're not going to be the
same size in game as they are in when we
actually draw the graphics so when we
import uh Sprites so what we want to do
is we want to control the way that it
actually upscales it so by setting this
to nearest it will go to the nearest
pixel and take it it won't blend pixels
if you change this to linear it will
linearly interpolate pixels okay which
will cause blurring or essentially it'll
look like anti-aliasing okay we don't
want that okay we want it to remain
sharp so that's what we
do all right fantastic so um text image
2D so we'll set DL Che to
2D uh we'll set okay so this does so uh
level zero internal format will be rgba
so you can see it reads it from right to
left rgba that's what we wanted in we
had it in BG which is why it would have
been a problem okay but we fix it now so
width
height uh border zero uh format again G
rgba um open has hearing issues
sometimes it doesn't hear us the first
time so once it another time uh okay now
this is going to be the actual format of
the actual um
uh stuff so we could we basically want
onsign bite right we would have had
these as bytes but we can't because Java
doesn't have unsigned bytes which mean
that they're signed and they range from
netive 128 to positive 127 we want to go
up to 255 so we have to use integers we
could have used shorts by the way short
would have totally been acceptable but
we wer with integers just be so um and
then we'll go buffer utils doc create in
buffer um and the capacity oh a this is
the wrong int
buffer uh
orff no thank you um create so was it
creating
buer okay so we want our one um and
we're going to take in uh the ARR uh Big
Data okay and there you go finally we'll
return
result done
so few things we may want/ need um bind
okay so that'll just simply
bind that so I guess we'll call
bind
um except we can't do it yet cuz we
don't actually have texture set yet so
we'll have to leave that like that but
we'll pop it here um and that'll bind
our
texture and we'll have unbind which does
exactly what you think it might do it
just does that essentially right so it
says it to
zero all right fantastic we could have
other things like get withd get he I
don't think we'll need them so we won't
them for now we'll see if we need them
later okay the last graphical thing we
probably need is a vertex array so a
Vertex array is essentially an array of
vertices we send that to the Shader
which tells the graphics card render
these vertices here and those vertices
of course make up our meshes or our
objects okay our like the physical shape
of our objects
so um yeah so we're going to make a
variety of vertex arrays here so the the
idea here is that when we create a
vertex right it takes in a float of
vertices uh a bite of indices and we'll
probably need texture coordinates as
well everything we create here will have
texture coordinat that's why I'm adding
this into the Constructor so what we do
have
though is a private in so we we'll need
a few things so count count is going to
be the amount of vertices we actually
render because we're using indices to
describe vertices it'll actually be the
length of indices not the length of
vertices okay that's important um
because we're yeah we're using indexed
vertices essentially so the indices
describe so we'll get to that when we
actually make them
so this will be using a lot of open gel
versions so or. lwjgl doop
dog11 will be one of them it'll probably
be
using uh 30 it'll probably be using 1.5
that probably is enough so GL gen
buffers which is 1.5 oh sorry gen arrays
is what we want okay so our Vio is our
vertex array object
so print uh not print
private um in vao okay we'll also have a
we'll also have a lot more that we don't
really need um we'll put them all here
though so we'll have a Vertex buffer
object which is a buffer of our vertices
right we'll have an index buffer object
which is a buffer for from our indices
and finally we'll have our texture
coordinates
that's big I'm going to name this TCS
instead of so it's smaller um texture
coordinates texture coordinate object
I'll call it oops okay so gen uh vertex
arrays is what we're looking for okay
and that's probably 3.0 yep G 30 all
right so now that we've done that we
should bind our vertex array so vertex
array is just essentially it's it's like
it's like a group of buffers so we want
all these buffers to be connected in a
way except for the indices really we
want these two to be connected right so
to do that we put them into a Vertex
array okay but really these buffers are
what actually store the data so G gen
buffers um we'll bind it because we want
to change it so we need to select the
buffer like selecting a layer in
Photoshop before we can do stuff to it
um so we've selected it now we call gel
buffer data the target being array
buffer it's just going to be this buffer
is simply going to be an array right um
now the data is going to be vertices now
well actually have to create a float
buffer for it so we just call um
wonderful buffer u. create um float
buffer R1 right
vertices um and then the usage will be
GL static draw all right this won't
actually change dynamically so we can
just leave it a static draw um once we
set these it's won't change okay great
so now we have to actually Supply a
Vertex attribute pointer so this is
important because and this is in I think
1.3 no
H this will probably be in
two I
expect yeah okay because it's related to
shaders and of course shaders came
around in two z um so the index being
zero so this stuff will make a lot more
sense on when we actually create our
shaders but essentially what we want to
do is we want to give it um what I'm
actually going to do is create some
static fields for this so we don't get
confused I think so in um in
Shader we we'll do is we'll create a few
things so public static final
int um
vertex so these are going to be
attribute locations so when we create
these in our shaders attributes are kind
of like uniforms except they're set
every single vertex essentially so
they're not set every time we draw
something or every time we call you know
set uniform attributes are set every
single um vertex okay so because of that
we they kind of contain data such as
vertex data which of course has to be
different for each vertex otherwise we'd
be drawing everything on top of each
other so we've got vertex we'll have um
the only other one we need is Tex
texture coordinate so I guess I'll just
have something like texture I'll call it
texture coordinate though like that to
make sure and that'll be one these
values will actually specify in our
shaders when we write them so you'll see
you'll see this um so Shader do uh
vertex right so that doesn't mean Shad
this is attributes so I think I'll just
go atrib just just
to CU it it can sound a bit confusing
it's like shaded vertex is it the vertex
Shad no it's the vertex attribute
location um so um now the count that's
next right yep size okay three why
because we're going to have an XY Z for
each vertex so this is going to be a
linear array of vertices so it'll be
like you know if we it'll be XY Z Comm
it'll be XY Z XY Z XY Z XY Z we want
three so we can be like oh okay it has
three components so that's why when I
every every three components we go back
to X essentially we go back to the
start um when we when we're reading this
okay so G float because they floats um
false for the uh I don't even know for
I'm just I always write false here um
let me just check what that false is for
uh normalize yes we don't want to
normalize them or they are not
normalized essentially um and the last
thing which is very important is that
you actually enable this vertex
attribute array okay zero so zero
because it's and I should not have
written zero but zero because it's that
okay so there we go um great so let's do
the textures now um so the uh texture
coordinate object I'll call this a
texture buffer object uh weal G buffers
again um we'll be obviously binding that
one um create FL buffer from the texture
coordinates which I'll just name
TCS I keep them like this um one El so
you guys can see now texture coordinates
won't be XYZ they'll be XY obviously
when we're reading in a 2D image there
is no such thing as that so we'll change
this to two Okay and change this to
tord awesome um anything else that looks
weird not really I mean obviously this
has to be that but apart from that
everything looks good in the hood okay
fantastic IC so um just menion we're not
using vbo anyway there no we not good
okay so finally IBO our index buffer
object so this will be GL gen buffers
again okay now the difference here is
that when we bind it um this will be an
element array buffer okay not a array
buffer it'll be an element array buffer
so different type of buffer um and when
we do Supply with
data
um ele array
buffer buffer u. create bite
buffer uh indices right and it'll have
the same usage and everything it's just
the type of buffer is different static
draw fantastic so we could unbind all
these um we probably should actually so
at the end I'll just go bind buffer glay
buffer zero and bind
buffer GL element array buffer zero
fantastic so now we do what we kind of
did before we um create some cool things
for it so so public void bind um we'll
uh bind our vertex
array so there's two things we need to
bind our vertex array which is vao and
our um element so we'll need to bind our
element array buffer as well so CH
element R buffer which is our indices so
we need to bind those two that's it um
this isn't really part of the vertex
array I should add
yeah so I'll just
bind vertex
array zero I'll put that at the bottom
all right so this isn't this element
array buff really isn't part of the
vertex array okay um which is why we
need to bind it separately okay
cool um so
unbind zero and zero
oops done okay great I'll just do do
them in this order so it looks nicer
okay great so the big one here is really
draw okay so public or draw um what that
will do is essentially draw elements so
G draw
elements
[Music]
um let's see so GL uh triangles is what
we're looking for G
triangles um
count right G sign
bite and zero all right and there we go
so essentially the mode that we're
drawing in will be triangles so we're
drawing triangles there's that many of
them so this will probably be six right
CU we'll have six vertices three
vertices per triangle and two triangles
make up something like a square which is
usually what we'll be drawing um so
that'll be six and then the type which
is unside B and then we've got no kind
of offset we've got no array offset so
just zero all right fantastic so if we
want to combine these two operations so
we don't have to call bind and draw
we'll just make a public uh public void
render which will simply call bind and
draw it won't worry too much about
unbinding here we'll just bind a draw
fantastic okay feels good to say say
this I think we're at about an hour and
a half in yeah almost in fact not even
we've done basically all of the engine
stuff now okay that's out of the way
which is amazing so now we can actually
make the game okay we should probably
check that these things for work first
okay um we're not going to cuz we're sh
on time we're just going to drive right
into it so I'm going to make a uh new
class called
level this will be um the level folder
all right this is going to represent a
level in our Flappy Bird game so this
will have a few different things for
example it will have a private vertex
array background all right so this will
be uh vertex array which is essentially
our background right
um our scrolling background in enough
flppy game let's make a quick um
Constructor here not a quick Constructor
slow Constructor um so what we'll do
here is we'll actually create the
background for example so let's make up
the the vertices for our background so
these are our BG vertices what I think
everything else will probably have its
own object so I'm not going to bother
calling it BG
vertices um okay great so these vertices
um we okay first thing we should do is
actually set up a projection Matrix so
our projection Matrix um what we'll do
is as follows when we initialize all of
this stuff what we want to do is we want
to uh create a new Shader so we'll have
a Shader all of our shaders will be
created statically by the way you'll see
so what we'll do is we'll create a um
public static void load all these will
load all all of our shaders and then
over here is where we have all of our
shaders so public static Shader um we
don't want to have we don't want to
basically have more than one instance of
the same Shader which is why I'm doing
it this way so public setic Shader
um let's just call this so background I
guess will background have its own
Shader probably I'll just call this BG
though GB garlic bread for those of you
who uh follow my streams and know what
I'm talking about um we won't create it
here we can't create it yet because that
involves open Shell Code and we have to
call load all after we've actually
instantiated shaded open ja or
initialized I should say in open ja so
Shader new uh so this will just be in
the shaders SL uh bg. vert for the
vertex Shader and then the fragment
Shader of course will be in um
frag there we go so now that that's done
over here we will call Shader load all
right once open gel's initialized we can
call this where if we want um so this is
like open gel initialization stuff as
well as Shader stuff anything related to
that texture there'll be a texture load
all as well um cuz again we shouldn't
have multiple uh instances of our
textures um so what we'll do here is
we'll say Shader BG right do set uniform
map 4 so the uni so this will be the
projection Matrix and this projection
Matrix all right let me create this
projection Matrix here so Matrix
4f PR Matrix so projection Matrix this
is kind of this is what we'll call it in
our Shader by the way as you can see
here
Um this can be called whatever you want
it to be called cuz we'll set it here
but it you know I just called it the
same so it makes sense um so this will
be a matrix 4f do orthographic right
left right I'm we know this is this
should be a 16x9 window I'm actually
going to make it from - 10 to 10 on the
X bottom will be - 16 um I've totally
mess this up so it's 169 and not 1610 so
we'll go like this and we'll say this
will be - 99 to positive 9 and then near
and far will simply be 1.0 um sorry
negative 1.0 for near and then 1.0 for
far all right that's it so this is what
our orthographic Matrix looks like okay
so once we've done that once we create
it we'll set it here we'll have to sh
we'll have to set it for all of our
shaders most likely okay so just keep
that in mind um that's why I've made it
an object here and I'll just put this in
there because we'll have to do a
multiple times I think so um in level
when I create these vertices I know now
that -10 is the
um oh sorry 16
is um you know what I I kind of do want
-10 to be that that side so what I'll do
instead is I will actually make this 10
and 10 and then I'll simply say that
this is going to be um so 10 * 9 /
right uh minus for this one that's
bottom
right yep um and then the top will
be just the same but positive all right
so there we go so now we're actually so
10 and 10 is now that and then that'll
be whatever it is um top and bottom will
be whatever it is um okay great so back
in level we can probably close most of
these now um so I'm going to set it to
-10 um
-10 * 9 / 16 uh 0 all right so this is
going to be our uh bottom left
corner um then we're going to go ahead
and create our uh top left corner now
this is not going to go all the way
across the screen uh I think this spr
will the the background graphic will
take up half out screen so this should
go to 0 0 all right I'll keep this nice
in line though and then again we'll go
of course positive and then negative
again all right there we go and then the
Z will just be zero I think at least for
now all right so we're creating this out
of two triangles we need six we need six
vertices don't we 1 2 three for the one
triangle and another three for the next
triangle now some of these are going to
be redundant so that's where indices
come in they stop us from making
redundant um vertices because
essentially indices are saying that
reuse the same vertices so
012 uh 23 0 means the first triangle
consists of 0 1 2 the second triangle
consists of 2 3 oh sorry 2 3 0 okay
that's how it works fantastic so texture
coordinates um which is specified as
flows for some reason again I don't know
this is I think this is an lj2 thing I
don't remember I'm just doing it the way
I know how so I don't waste too much
time um 01
cuz we're remember we're starting at the
bottom yeah so we want the Y to be one
cuz we're dropping down um 0
0 uh 1
Z and 1 one so these are basically
setting for the vertices what the text
coordinates are indices apply to both
vertices and text coordinates in this
case so uh this is going to be that that
0 0 is going to be our top left which is
exactly what this represents and Etc
right right fantastic so now let's make
our vertex array out of it so we got
it's called background so we'll set it
equal to new vertex array float vertices
uh indices and TCS texture coordinates
right there we go fantastic so we want
to draw this with an actual texture
though um I'll quickly make a
render U method which really what this
will be doing right um let's just test
it and make sure that this level
actually does get drawn without a
texture first of all so what we'll do is
we'll say in render they'll be they'll
just go back we'll just go back around
render right nice and simple we don't
need to bind it first and draw it we can
just hit do render um this will be done
with a certain Shader so Shader BG
do enable so it doesn't know what Shader
is let's import that control shift o um
and then we'll be nice and disable at
the end even though we don't really need
to all right fantastic so now All That
Remains is writing the Shader to display
our background obviously not All That
Remains for the rest of the game so
under Flappy yeah I'm going to right
click hit new folder we'll create that
shaders folder that we specified in our
source code over here and then b.v B.F
frag are the file names so right click
new file not class file right um bg.
vert we'll write this first and then
copy it let me just quickly boost up
this text I always forget to do that for
videos um so on basic and then text
font just put that up to
12 all right fantastic so version 330
core what we're interested in so I'll
make it fairly compatible down to like
version 3
My3 um so void
main
so uh essentially what's going to happen
here for our BG is we're going to take
in um those two wonderful attributes of
ours so this and this right at position
zero and one so to do that we write
layout
location equals z that's where the zero
is yeah in cuz we're taking data in to
the Shader from the uh CPU in this case
cuz it's the vertex Shad so yeah it's
coming from the CPU V 4 is the data it
is and position now the thing is our
position is in VC 3 we need a VC four
here but it's we're giving it VC 3
that's all right because we remember we
have specified in our vertex array that
uh this is a three component Vector
essentially okay so that's fine as in
it's there's three things so it'll just
create one or something for the fourth
one which is fine cuz the fourth one
isn't really used for positioning
obviously it's something else entirely
which I'm not going to get into right
now um the other thing we need is layout
location one of course and that's our
texture so this is act this is actually
a v two and I'll just call this TC
texture coordinates right now we also
need a projection Matrix so uniform mat
4 PR Matrix y PR Matrix so it's called
PR Matrix important because it has to be
the same thing that we specified here
that's the location of it it'll get it
hopefully it should find it um and then
that's really all we need for now so
what we'll do is we'll set our GL
position yeah equal to our our
projection Matrix multiplied by the V
the by the vertex positions that's why
this has to be a v four this if we can
take in a V 3 the other thing we could
do we can take an a 3 and then do
something like this yeah personally I
think it's a bit cleaner just taking a v
four cuz open will sort that stuff out
for us anyway so we'll do that um and
then that's it that's our position set
up now we need a fragment Shader which
is going to essentially give us the
color of the fragment which in this case
is the color of the pixel so we'll call
this um bg.
frag we'll copy and paste this for now
right um we'll get rid of most of this
stuff in fact all of it uh we will have
an
out VC 4
color all right we'll put we'll pop this
into location zero as well so this will
actually tell our Graphics C what color
this fragment should be okay and we'll
set the color right now equal to
something nice such as it has to be a v
four by the way so
rgba um W we'll go like a nice blue 0.2
0.3 0.8 and then Alpha channel will be
just one all right fantastic so
hopefully this will work um we need to
obviously render our level though we're
not calling this at all so in our main
um we'll go ahead and we'll go private
level
level we'll uh import
that um and then we'll call in between
this level. render all right ready let's
see if this
works crash okay we actually got a lot
of Errors so uh failed to compile Vex sh
invalid profile call layout what is that
so something's probably going wrong in
our reading code um so it didn't comp
pile that's weird core layout so this is
probably string Builder I I bet we've
done the wrong thing in string Builder
we probably it's not I think it's as
string instead of two string actually
now that I think about it um so this is
in Shad util no this is in
fileutils so not two string cuz that
probably isn't
even oh no no we we even checked that
that should be right let's quickly put a
breakpoint
here yeah let's just quickly put a break
point here and see okay so first of all
result
is core layout oh whoops so when you're
reading this in when you're pending this
make sure you put a new line character
at the end of that all right that is the
problem good let's relaunch this now so
we need a new line after every
line okay uh break point Let's ignore
that and
continue okay level. render null pointer
exception oh we never made the level
whoops so when we do this uh at the end
of here for example we'll just go new
level and that'll of course prow the
object my bad I forgot to do that and
here we go so good no errors but we see
nothing so we should be seeing a
fragment we should be seeing half house
screen essentially being blue okay that
did not work so now it's debugging time
uh the culprits are most
likely well first of all this no that's
right my bad so -10 to 10 -10
to
101 to1 so our Matrix is correct
assuming this is right right left top
bottom near far left right left right
bottom top yep just checking maths math
is always good to check 0 one these are
all correct these
indices yes okay so this is right so the
maths the maths is correct
um or at least it looks correct we never
really know if it is um it's loaded the
things in successfully uh let's quickly
check see this is what we don't have
time for I was hoping we could get away
without doing this 1 hour 40 though
we're not actually making too bad of a
time we'll have to really accelerate the
the Flappy bir stuff in a minute but
everything looks all right let's just
make sure everything here is being set
correctly uh it sure does look like it
um the drawer
is yeah so
we're are we getting an open G error
that is the problem we could check
pretty easily but I'm not going to just
yet so um let me just make sure that's
all
correct yeah okay everything looks fine
um we've enabled our Shader which does
do the correct thing um
in here let's quickly get the open jail
eror so um G get
error so if I doesn't equal
GL I think it's
like gel no error so if it doesn't equal
no
error uh we'll just print
I okay 1282 that means uh invalid
operation so something we have done is
invalid um it's this actually so before
we set the Shader we need to um bind
it all right so you need to bind the
Shader before you set
it
I might actually um and this is enable
and disable um I might actually get this
to do it automatically because it's
going to be a lot of extra code yay half
screen is blue fantastic that worked
okay so I might actually leave the I'll
change this in a minute and I'll also
leave the arrow checking in here because
as you can see that was helpful so um in
and what I'll do here is I'll I'll have
a private
Ballo enabled
false so um
enabled
true
false now the problem is this will not
always work but it will sometimes work
because it relies on us un unbinding
everything after we finished using it
which is probably not going to happen um
but it's all right uh in fact this
should somewhat be static I think um
because that will disable not just this
shade B every shed in the history but
that's all right um oh I got to do it
for everything
here um okay we'll quickly do it so if
not
enabled bind or
enable this is all we're going to do
okay I'm not really too fussy about it
this won't work every time but it'll
work for what we need it such as over
here so uh
error
so now we should get no
errors all right good no error codes
fantastic so everything is fine now
let's get on with this so let's give it
a texture now so what I'm actually going
to do is give us give ourselves some
awesome textures so our Flappy um let me
quickly just find my
other
flappiness so in resources so what I've
got is essentially I'm going to make a
new folder in um in this Flappy Bird
thing right I want to call it
res sens for resources right this is in
here so if I refresh it'll appear here
right um I'm going to paste in a bunch
of uh F Assets Now this is too much
stuff we don't need half of this so what
we've got here if you will show me a
better view mate um extra large icons so
we've got um that's not what I wanted
did I remove something that we needed
probably so there's our background we
don't need that um where are my pipes I
specifically had pipes somewhere and
they're not here anymore and that makes
me sad so where did you go pipes why
have you where have you
gone I swear I had them I must have
deleted them oh no this is not good
things are going
wrong so somewhere what the this is
weird Okay okay anyway so we've got some
pipes that I've extracted somewhere
we'll deal with them later I'll find
them don't you worry but we've got our
background and we've got our bird and I
don't know why it's called bird C but
we've got our bird and we've got our
background this is a JPEG for some
reason but it doesn't matter okay we we
should still be able to read it all
right jpeg bird so we want to apply this
to this suspiciously similar sized area
so to do that it's it'll be a bit
stretch but that's all right to do that
we need to uh it should be fairly easy
with our current engine so what we what
we can do is go into our level
class um
private private
texture BG
texture BG BG texture will
equal new
texture path is um
rebg do jpeg
and we will before we enable this stuff
and render we will also
um go ahead and
go uh not Shader um BG texture
dot bind and I guess we'll call unbind
at the end of it now few things remain
uh mainly our shaders um first thing we
actually have to do is enable um the
whole uh we actually have to set a
uniform one I being uh Tex or something
we'll call to one when we do this we
want to set um the active
texture because open gel supports
multitexturing so it might not know
which texture we're talking about um so
I think this is in one3 um but we need
to basically set the active texture so
GL active texture there it is oh it's
raining outside cool it's summer so
that's interesting to like for example
one like it can be zero but we'll set it
to one and if we set it to one we need
to make sure that we set this to one
okay if we set this to zero we set this
to zero all right simple as that um this
is which texture we're referring to when
we bind a texture so this is the active
texture so if we want to bind multiple
textures we call G active texture zero
we bind something then we call G active
texture 2 we bind something else right
simple as that great so that being said
back in here we need to now make sure
that our shaders actually take in stuff
from the the textures from the from the
textur so what we need to do is for
example create a nice struct that will
send out data we'll call vs out vertex
Shader out into our fragment Shader so
out from our vertex Shader goes into our
fragment Shader okay in from our vertex
Shad in from our fragment Shader takes
start room for the vertex Shader all
right so we'll have V 2 TC right and
then at the end we'll simply be setting
the reason I made this um a struct
instead of just out V 2 TC is because
will'll probably have more than multiple
data it's nice to have an struct nice
and organized so we'll set VC out.
texture coordinate equal to Tex Co also
it stops us from accidentally using
wrong variables sometimes because we
prefix everything with VC out now all
right great so that is some nice rain
I'm actually excited it's raining
outside I feel like going out now um
anyway uh um what am I doing here so um
let's copy and paste this uh struct of
ours structure put it here here
obviously there going to be in data now
the this name has to remain the same
right it has to be called Data okay
otherwise it will refer to a different
struct and won't be able to find it
right so this is the name of the struct
this is the name of
the I don't know this is our name for
the struct so we'll call this Fs in
right so instead of taking blue yeah or
as the color even though it is a very
nice and respectable blue we want to
actually set this to um our texture
coordinate which will essentially be
texture yeah uh the texture which we're
about to take in here so text is what
we've called it that's why I said it in
the in the um set uniform one I thing in
our Java code as well um and then uh
fsmtc fantastic so text um let's create
that so this will simply be a uniform
sampler 2D text so this will be supplied
here uh essentially by setting it to one
in the BG when we actually B bind a text
should put it into one if we run this
now we should see look at that fantastic
we've got our thing in our game awesome
we're getting somewhere we're doing
stuff this is exciting so um we've
actually got the entire game to make now
I've just realized which will probably
take a while and we're at 1 hour 49
minutes I'm actually confident we can
pull this off in 40 minutes okay so
let's quickly make
this okay um I'm just going to have some
water first though how are you guys
enjoying the video so far pretty cool
huh
I hope so otherwise I'm just sitting
here making Flappy Bird again on a
Saturday
afternoon which is the life so yeah so
what we want to do now is back in
level we probably want to make a
scrollable background right that sounds
reasonable so to do that um we're going
to need quite the setup because of
course we need to repeat we need to
repeat stuff right as in we need the
background to be repeatable um as we as
we move whoops not print as we move
forward this background should scroll
but we don't want to create a
million different background meshes we
just want basically two or three that'll
fill the screen ups and then we'll kind
of loop them in a way which will be
pretty cool so to set up a cool system
like that um what we actually need to do
is generate a bunch of stuff okay um to
start off with I'll make a I'll make an
integer called X scroll and I'll set it
equal to zero right X scroll is going to
be our horizontal scroll amount so
essentially in our update method which
we need to actually make sure updates at
a
reasonable rate um we're going to
increase X scroll or rather we're going
to decrease X scroll okay because of
translation stuff so we're going to
decrease X scroll all right um what's
going to happen is when we actually set
our I
guess um background stuff we're going to
draw it a bit differently than you might
think we bind the background we enable
the Shader and then what we do is we
actually have a for Loop so we'll
render we also need another variable
um I'm going to call it map so I is less
than map plus 4 so we'll run to four of
them i++ so what we'll do is let me
quickly just create this map so map will
also be an integer
guess we'll set it to zero for now so
what map is going to be is it's going to
be a bit similar to xcr except this will
be the actual how should I say this kind
of the location
of H I don't know this will advance the
background so I think a better name for
it is probably going to be something
like I'll refactor it and call this BG
scroll or
BG
um BG I don't
know
uh map we'll leave it as map um so what
we'll do is we'll say if so X scroll
will scroll right and we'll use that for
multiple things by the way not just this
but the X scroll if um if if the reverse
of that cuz obviously we're going
negative um and you'll see why by the
way because we're we're moving out map
left right that's why X scroll is going
negative but if Negative X scroll mod a
value such as 300 roughly is going to
equal zero we'll Advance our map yeah so
we'll Advance the position in which we
render our Maps so what we'll do here
and four might be Overkill we'll see but
what I'm going to do here is I'm
actually going to set
um uh the background
shaders
um Matrix right this is going to be the
view Matrix so VW
Matrix
um we'll set it equal to Matrix
4f that'll translate uh new Vector 3F
and so this will be um I right
times let's call it like I don't know
10 plus X scroll all right uh and
then we won't we obviously don't want to
translate the map in any other direction
so we'll do something like that and then
we will now we we don't want to render
it every time cuz rendering as you know
will actually bind and draw so we don't
want to bind it every time we l want to
bind it once and then draw it so that
being said uh let's change this to draw
and then over here we'll go
backround do bind okay so we bind it
once and then draw it like four times
okay let's see what this looks like once
we fix all these things um that should
not have a bracket there and that should
have an extra one here all right so we
need to sort out the whole update
situation because what I assume will
happen is if we if we put level. update
into here it's going to go way too fast
because it's in here so let's just
quickly okay it's not okay so we don't
have a VW Matrix yet let's add that into
our Shader so this is going to be really
simple okay all it's going to do is it's
going to be the same as this
Matrix and we're going to multiply it by
The View
Matrix so this is like the camera's
position think of it that way so if we
were using the backgrounds because the
backgrounds position that would be
something like model Matrix so if we run
this yeah you can see it goes very fast
in fact it kind of runs out of thingy so
we'll probably have to deal with that it
runs for a good while but then it runs
out so we'll have to tweak probably this
very well so let's go back here and
let's create a timer so that that only
run 60 times per second cuz right now
we're running incredibly fast so to do
that let's do a a bunch of stuff so long
um last time is going to be system.
current time this is just a basic FPS
counter essentially SL timer to make
sure our update only runs 60 times per
second double NS = 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so
this is a conversion from uh this is our
Tech rate essentially but it's going to
convert our nanocs so we'll actually be
using Nano time rather Nano time all
right last time um and now
okay so double Delta is
zero
um so uh Delta plus equals now minus
last
time / NS so instead of dividing by that
I'm dividing by this to get it into a
nice kind of format so basically every
time Delta reaches one we have um
reached uh we've done it 60 times per
second so this is a this is a bit
different to Delta time anyway you'll
see this will work I promise um so Delta
minus minus uh updates Plus+ and then
we'll run the update here so updates is
going to be an integer which tracks how
many times we update stuff per second so
that should always be 60 I'm just
putting it there for um debug purposes
and then frames so here what we'll do
first of all we need to actually set
last time it's now otherwise we'll get
nowhere um we'll call our update there
we've done that good over here we'll
call render and then we'll call we'll
see how many times we called it per
frame so frames um now this is the big
one if system. current time milliseconds
minus timer which will cre in a minute
it's greater than thousands th
milliseconds is 1 second so what we're
essentially saying
is um once per
second yeah firstly we need to actually
increase timer by a thousand yeah so
that it does it again next second um
we'll set um frames to zero and updates
to zero because we want to reset updates
per second frames per second every
second um and we'll print out updates
plus UPS plus frames plus FPS how is our
recording going good 157 nice so um now
that that is there um we should be able
to uh run this H run slower no it's
still running fast slow um great so
we're running at 60 frames per second
but that's still incredibly fast uh W
okay so this has
freaking okay so this is vsync anyway
we'll unsync it later um this is going
very fast so let's go X scroll times
like 0.03 or
something how's that speed looking good
let's see if it runs
out oh here it is
so we'll do again soon yeah so let's
boost this we'll probably have to tune
this quite a bit I don't have time for
that though so I'm just going to try 335
and hope that magical value
works okay that actually looks like it's
kind of working all right anyway here's
our scrollable background you can see
it's scrolling now and it will go on
forever and we're only drawing like four
times I wonder if three will
work it might
it might not so essentially what it does
is when it when it knows that it that
this thing is out of view it will put it
over here and render it here so that's
the thing it's Runing the same thing
like three times in this case Okay three
actually seems to work so I guess we'll
go with three um two won't because we'll
run out straight away so here you'll
actually see what happens when it gets
out of this it'll put it
here see cool huh all right anyway
that's our scrollable background done so
that actually was not too painful
luckily let's continue on Now with uh
our game so now would probably be a good
time to render pipes but we don't have
pipes because I don't know what happened
to my texture so let's go ahead and run
let's go ahead and do the bird first and
then I'll I'll find the pipes don't you
worry um
so uh under level I'm going to make a
new class called bird not bird X bird um
and under bird or inside bird um is
going to be a lot of bird related things
so we'll create a float size which will
be our bird size which will just be one
we'll create a mesh for it so vertex
array
mesh um we'll create a position for it
which will be a vector 3 F so we'll just
uh instantiate that like that so it's
zero by default of course
um cuz that'll set everything to zero as
you can see um
and let's see we'll need a
texture um let's import that as well
control shift O command shift on Mac um
we got position we'll have a rotation of
that doesn't need to be a vector of
course cuz we're only dealing with Z
rotation can just be a float um we'll
have uh let's see we'll have a Delta so
this is going to be our kind
of I guess our y Delta I should probably
call it but what you called it that so
public bird so this is going to be very
similar to how we created um our
background so I'm actually going to copy
stuff from that so in
level this is what we did right bird is
going to be very simple so we've got
vertices we' got this stuff I don't know
why you indented everything you fool um
so this will be replaced by MH this will
be replaced by texture this will be
bird.png I believe am I right I'm right
so this bird up conveniently has
transparent areas around it which is
good it's also a bit not perfect but
whatever we'll we'll deal with that
um okay so why is everything indented
okay so we have obviously have to change
this this is basically all we have to
change by the way these are going to be
the same so um this will
be minus size / two so size is going to
be the whole size see so we have to go
uh size and then um from from left to
right and size is going to be divid by
two otherwise otherwise our size would
be size time 2 uh minus size / 2 and
Z
comma quickly replace all that stuff
with our cool stuff get r that com at
the end I think you might be able to
keep it actually ja might let you get
away with that um and then we'll simply
do this right that'll set our stuff
correctly so now we've got four vertices
and the size of our bird which right now
is one
um so that should be about the right
size for this projection Matrix of
course um cool so we'll have an update
obviously
oops public void
update we'll have a
render public void
render okay um and what we'll do is
insert
here we will um enable our bird Shader
which we haven't created yet but we will
so let's just create let's just do that
Shader bird.
enable Shader bird.
disable um
and bird oh sorry taxture
bind and mesh.
render
all right great so one thing we should
do for
our uh thing eventually set up the
Shader as well for our
bird but we'll do that later okay cool
so um that is looking pretty good so we
do need to actually set up our bird
Shader so inside Shader I'll make
another one called
bird this is going to be slightly
different from the background one just a
bit though and we need to cre some
really sweet lighting into this game as
well of
course so we'll get around to that as
well so bird do rag uh I'm just going to
copy these really um copy paste so b.
frag will now be called bird. frag and
bver will be called bird Dover um so in
our vertex Shader for our bird let's
make some magic happen so
um I'm just thinking I think it'll be
pretty much the same for now I will add
some other changes such as lighting in
fact this might actually just not even
need its own Shader but you know for now
we'll for now we'll kind of keep it in
there I I'm assuming so I think what
we'll do is we'll um we will have to add
in actually we will need a model Matrix
and we might not need a view Matrix so
much so the view Matrix I'll just set
that equal to
um an identity matrix by default in case
we don't otherwise if we multiply
against it and a zero it'll fail um and
we'll set a model Matrix so that'll be
Zero by as well but we will set it so
this will be time V Matrix time model
Matrix time so model
view projection matrix model view
projection Matrix there we go um so this
ml Matrix will be set to the position of
our bird um
so under shadow. bird. enable shadow.
bird. set uniform map 4f ml Matrix I did
copy it
actually no okay um and we will set that
to Matrix
forf dot translate uh Vector being our
position awesome so now quickly let's
just make it so that we can uh just move
our bird in all directions just to make
sure everything is working in that sense
so
gfw do
glfw
key um up we'll go
positiony minus minus oh no don't do
don't do all of that okay
position uh is that good let's just
import
that so this should be f plus
actually
okay so
down
left
right this will be minus minus this will
be minus minus all right cool so we're
moving this stuff around now um we'll
deal with that stuff later as well cool
so uh let's go into our level so level
will create own bird private bird
bird
bir equals new
bird and uh I guess after we will B rer
see what we got no bird not good so no
open Gil eras either so that is
suspicious um shed out a bird is a real
thing
right looks like
it
um interesting
so what do we set that to and the
position oh we haven't set up the
projection Matrix yeah that's what
happened so we need to do this again but
for
bird basically the exact same thing
right and we still don't see a bird why
you not hear a bird um okay so let's
just make sure that's all right sh out
up Bird Okay Pro Matrix check uh all of
this position stuff that should have
been fine right where's our mesh what do
we say that to vertices
indices um that's looking good this is
bd. PNG which is check um okay I'm going
to probably say it's because of the
order we're entering this in so let's
just bring this up slightly closer to
the camera so I'm just going to put this
in
negative one we're not getting jail
error so I assume that's right um that
did absolutely nothing let's stop
rendering the background
entirely not that way though um don't
draw
that there's our Bird Okay so suspicious
then that Bird's not rendering um we did
set near
to1 so why then
that's our bir right yep so why does
that work then suspicious very
suspicious this whole thing but I'm
going to just roll with it because we
don't have time to debug it um Okay cool
so there's our bed uh and if we use the
arrow keys we should be able to move
this apparently not
um why oh we're not calling update
that's why let's go into this is going
to be very fast by the way this bird is
just going to disappear so let me
quickly change this to like something
like
that um so left as minus so
down Okay so let's quickly call update
in this is going to be the longest video
I've ever put out on my channel by the
way so I really hope you guys enjoy this
because who long video and it's all in
one take as well which is crazy okay we
can move this bird now fantastic our
game is looking phenomenal ready to ship
almost except for the whole game part um
so we should probably make that then so
flappy bird uh let's start him off
in let's do all of the bird stuff right
now except for like Collision cuz we
have nothing to collide against yet um
we're going to do this so our bird is
going to be basically falling at all
times that's just what he does he's a
Flappy Bird he doesn't really know how
to Flap unless we press space bar and
I'm typing what I'm saying
um fall so what we'll do is we'll we'll
just the Delta right that's the amount
we're falling by we're going to set that
to um minus like 0.15 or something that
should be about right I think
um we're in
level I knew something was off about
this whole
thing so full um so we will get rid of
this I don't need that
anymore that was just for testic
purposes so four Delta is that okay
um what we're going to do is
say oh
actually no we won't do we won't do that
yet we will do this this will be a
static fall which we'll do when we
actually lose the game actually I've
just decided so what we'll do is we'll
say um we'll go really simple we'll say
position Y is going to be subtract sub
raed by Delta okay so we're going to
fall based on the Delta whatever that
may be so right now if it is uh that and
we fall we'll just go down
like like that
so um this should be positive but anyway
um we'll go down I promise so if we do
flap though if input
dot uh
Keys um
let's just make this a bit let's just
make this a touch better huh let's go in
here and say public static
bull lean is key
down
um uh in key code this will just return
Keys key code I think it will just look
slightly better in when we use it okay
there we go done so if input do is key
down
um gfw dogf do so we'll import gfw
statically
static there we go so we don't have to
prefix that all the time so if so key um
space bar
right uh so if that is down right we'll
go ahead and we'll actually say uh Delta
so we want it to fall at an increasing
rate so I'll probably just say something
like if we do actually have if we do
actually hit space bar we'll set it
equal to
like .5 so we we're going up at about
that rate as I just showed you via fall
right that should be probably good
otherwise um we want to constantly be
falling by probably about that much that
should be about right we might tweak
that a bit so if we run this now and
what is up here get out if we run this
now um it should fall but if we hit
space bar you can see we and look we're
basically playing Flappy Bird already
because the map is advancing which makes
it look like the bird is moving even
though the bird is not moving at all
he's just going up and down in fact if I
were to uh not animate X scroll at all
this would look
weird
well okay there's something quite wrong
when we're actually closing the game so
we'll probably should fix that later um
anyway
um weird how our map just disappeared oh
cuz that's always zero that's
why so this looks quite it looks like
we're just going up and down but if you
suddenly add the magic of
Animation uh it looks like we're moving
all right now one thing that's not that
one thing that's happening right now is
we're getting a white background okay
what we need to do it's very
simple a we actually need blending but B
if we go to bird. frag and we check we
say if
color W which is our Alpha channel so XY
Z is RGB and then nothing pass Z as we
go back to W if color. W
is less than one we can just
discard and that will discard that
fragment completely okay so if we launch
that okay um that's weird that should
not have happened this is in bird right
if call is less than one discard why did
that just got our whole thing oh
obviously because we haven't set the
color yet LOL
um so there we go so that fixes the
whole thing so that kind of gets rid of
the whole open jail planing thing
because it's just simply saying don't
draw that particular pixel or fragment
yeah so there we go so now our bird
looks better now we need a bit of
rotation to make this look a bit better
and looks like our map is kind of
bleeding it is okay we'll fix that later
um so if color W yeah so we've got that
down now what we need to do is probably
add a bit of rotation to our bird okay
now luckily um with we've got a
fantastic way to rotate our bird all we
need to do is we need to go ahead and
say rotation is going to probably equal
something
like minus Delta time about 90° or so
okay
so because negative Delta is going to be
roughly in the range that we're looking
for so if we go ahead and um this
translate right we're going to go ahead
and multiply it by a rotation
matric which we create just by
specifying this so if this doesn't work
is probably something with rotation
mouths but hopefully it will work
awesome look at that so that's that's
pretty good you can see the fter he
falls the more he tilts down as well
which is fantastic and look he's like
flapping all it's missing is some Flappy
animation which I'm sure you guys can
add but there we go so we've got Flappy
Bird kind of working pretty well I think
that's good in fact everything's pretty
much done in this class what we do want
to say is uh for a game over we'll do
something else as well but it's looking
pretty good right now and we're at 2
hours and 15 I thought I'd have this
done 15 minutes probably not but yeah
okay okay so let's make the pipes now so
let me quickly just locate my pipes
because something has happened with them
and it's not terribly amazing okay so
here's my pipe there you are I found you
luckily cuz that would have been awkward
if I didn't Flappy resources pipe look
here it is fantastic um it's also
Alfred cool right so that we don't have
that stuff fantastic so pipes um I'm
going to make another Shader for the
pipes I know I'm making shaders for
everything but the reason is I just I'm
taking the safe road because I believe
that we
probably will need differing shaders
once we add lighting cuz maybe lighting
will be different I don't know for now
we'll just keep it like this uh when we
add a new Shader the most important
thing we do
is give it the right
parameters so pipe pipe
pipe I also need to do that cool fade in
Shader that we had at the beginning of
FL about every time you started as you
guys probably remember um from the
preview at the beginning of this video
so there we go pipe done okay good so
pipes how do they work pipes are static
that's one thing we need to note um
pipes will actually need their own
shaders actually because they um some of
them will be inverted as you'll see but
the way that pipes will work is uh
they'll be in level they'll kind of be
static in the sense that this pipes
don't change they're the same pipes over
and over again right so we don't want to
have a new instance of them for each
pipe so what we do instead is We have
basically a somewhat static class um
each pipe will have its own position
though so we we'll blend this stuff so
position equals
new Vector
3F we'll have a static float
okay so this will be the width of the
pipe which I'm going to say set to about
.5 and the height which I'll set to like
eight that should be roughly correct
um our width of our screen is 20 so I
think we'll play around with height a
lot I think because unless that just
happened to be perfect because we will
um we'll probably uh need to make it
either it might be too difficult or too
easy depending on cuz FL bird the
difficulty really depends on
um you know stuff so we'll have texture
so right now you might have noticed that
textures are being loaded in not
statically like I said they would be
that's because I don't actually think
we'll need to load like we don't have
multiple instances so yeah so we'll have
this Matrix 4f which will be
our like PR Matrix no sorry not PR
Matrix ml Matrix
um and finally we need a mesh so that'll
be static as well cuz that won't change
so we'll pop all of our static stuff
down a bit okay great so over here we'll
uh we'll go ahead and we'll make a
public static void
like create or or compile or something
we'll call it create um where we set up
all of our stuff so back in bird let's
go to bird quickly copy its stuff
paste it into
here without the indentation
please as long as it's easy to fix I
guess it's fine so um yeah so we'll just
start off
with 00
0 one I guess
um and then we'll set this stuff
accordingly so we'll go with uh we'll go
0 so we go down the bottom with
um width and then we'll just do high
like
this all right everything else stays the
same we probably kind of static this out
actually as long as everything's this
kind of shape but it's all right we'll
leave it here um mesh and then of course
the test shell will be pipe. PNG that is
correct I
believe yep pipe. PNG fantastic so
there's our stuff um when we do create a
new pipe
though
public pipe we'll probably take in an X
and
Y so you guys might be a bit confused
because there's a static method and then
we're making other stuff here but um you
will see don't you worry so position
doxal X position y y and we need to
create a matrix out of it so Matrix
equals Matrix oh sorry not Matrix we
called it um ml Matrix equals Matrix uh
for . translate of course and it'll just
be basic on position that's it I don't
actually know if we'll need this we
might we'll see
so oh this will be um yes this is the
model Matrix and of course it'll be
translated based on the uh we we will
need this stuff for Collision detection
actually now that I think about it but
this will be translated on um because
remember the camera is moving as well as
the actual pipes have their own location
so yeah we will need them um okay we're
going to need a bunch of uh well I want
to make position I want to make
position
public I could I'll just just to make it
explicit for you I'll make gets for the
position things the reason I'm doing
this is because um when we start writing
the Collision code which will just be a
simple rectangular Collision thing uh
it'll look better basically if you guys
can see what's going on so um public
static vertex
array get
mesh return
mesh do the same for the
texture uh create create the texture yep
okay
um and so we'll probably render it out
actually in the other in in I think
because we have to lender multiple times
and
stuff so public static float get
width so these are just the static cuz
the the width and height doesn't change
as opposed to X and
Y um and height will return height all
right this is quite a long coding
session are we hitting 3 hours yet two
and a half almost oh we're getting this
okay so back back in
level um I'm probably less excited than
I was at the beginning of the video to
be honest back in level uh I'm going to
actually make a render pipes method
which will be in charge of rendering
pipes so public we make this private
private void render
pipes um so we'll enable the pipe Shader
of
course
[Music]
um so Shader do
pipe do set let's set our Matrix right
this will be our so the view Matrix will
be set to Shader uh sorry uh string name
the view Matrix will be set to
essentially like our view Matrix um we
might add some parallaxing in if we're
cool and we are pretty cool so I think
we will but we'll keep it the same as
this for now instead of obviously I * 10
we just have X scroll cuz there is no I
um um we're not R multip multiple times
here so we need to bind the texture so
p. texture. bind we need to
um bind the mesh so we are actually
doing this we're not calling render
we're going to be calling bind and draw
because we're going to we're going to do
it kind of the same thing here how we do
it in multiple times so for Loop time
for I equal z i is less than how many
pipes are going to fit on the screen I'm
going to say 10 so 5 * 2 in the sense of
five there and five on the top five on
the bottom that's 10 I believe if my MTH
is correct of course it is um okay so uh
now that we've got that let's go back to
Shader pipe. uniform Matt 4 so now we
will be say we'll be for we'll be
setting the model Matrix so ml Matrix to
the pipes model Matrix so pipes we need
to create pipes and then we need to get
their model Matrix so what we'll do is
we'll have
a public Matrix
4f get model
Matrix return ml Matrix all right cool
so let's create these pipes so the cool
thing about this is we only really need
pipes yeah we really only need 10 pipes
because the thing is these pipes will be
reused they'll be recycled so private
pipe array pipe P equals new pipe and
we'll just have 10 of them so we don't
even need Dynamic arrays so I'll just
write five times two so it looks better
um and it's more clear I guess so 5 * 2
five on the top five on the bottom those
are our pipes and then once we you know
we'll be able to recycle them the same
the same way we do with um our map which
is awesome
so I will in the Constructor here I'll
probably just we'll probably just have
like private World
create or like create pipes or
something
um we'll call that from the
Constructor and what we'll do is we'll
say pipes
so um this will probably be
created
okay pipes will be this will be update
pipes I
think and you'll see the
difference so we'll have a generate
pipes I'll just I won't call them I
guess we'll call them create pipes so
this will this is the initial one that
we run just to you know instantiate each
object and whatnot um I guess uh so 4 in
IAL z i is less
than um I is less than like 5 * 2 I
guess or the length of it um we'll say
pipes side equals new pipe now this is
where the fun begins so we probably want
to say something like
um
oh this is going to be hard well not too
difficult of course but still
hard
um
[Music]
H okay here is what I'm going to
say
um so here's what we'll do we'll pop it
at
so we'll okay so we'll have an
index uh private int index we'll set
that to zero what we'll do is we'll say
We'll create the pipe at
index
[Music]
um um times like three um we want to set
it at a
random we'll put it to four right now
this is going to be the top pipe now we
need to make the bottom pipe so we'll go
I + 1 right so when I say 5 * 2 I do
want to say I + = 2 okay um and we'll
need index for something else that's why
I've made index and you'll see that in a
minute um because we do want to actually
plus equals 2 to the index as well
you'll see that in action later just
it's all in my head right now and I
can't explain it yet I want to show you
um okay so over here when we create this
what we'll do is we need to create it at
the same X as this okay okay so instead
of hard coding it I will say pipe equals
new pipe um pipes I which is the one we
just created do get X right so it's the
same X it needs to be aligned yeah it
needs to be aligned in terms of
horizontally um and it'll be pipes it'll
be whatever the Y
is yeah which will which is four right
now minus like
10 okay
that should generate our pipes fairly
well and we'll update them later let's
just make sure this gives us something
cool so create pipes so when we render
them we'll render this stuff so we'll
set this equal to pipes
I dog model
Matrix and of course we also need to
actually uh render them um so we need
to
um oh let's see
yeah so P.G mh.
draw all right and then let's unbind
both the texture and the
mesh unbind unbind not bind
unbind all right fantastic so let's give
this a wh we're not calling render pipes
though so let's do that before we render
the the bird I'd say and see what this
looks like if anything oh a crash uh is
it a what crash is it it's a null
pointer exception so what's
null I'd say texture really is the only
thing could be null so get textur ring
texture oh create this needs to happen
so we need to actually call in in here
uh before we create the pipes here um or
in fact as we're creating the pipes
pipes pipe.
create all right and then we'll call
that and voila oh look at that pipes
that looks amazing H we our bird just
fell
though come on bird you still alive
there you are yay that is way too hard
first of all
um let's
say
okay let's make it let's make the Gap a
bit wider okay that's still a bit too
high we want them to be at random
intervals though don't we so let's
create a random private random random
equals new random so this is where the
fun part of the game begins when we
actually get to you know create stuff
and experiment and there's no there's no
like frustration or anything well in a
way so we'll to this time 4 I'm just
going to go random. next float times
time times like four see what that looks
like okay that's actually really good
the only problem is our textures are not
inverted when they should be on the top
so this is actually looking pretty good
and it's already infuriating me how
silly this game is so we're actually
getting somewhere because okay so the
pipes don't Loop that's too but let's
fix let's fix the texture first so it's
going to be a pretty easy fix I'm going
to under render pipes um simply make a
quick uh we'll set a uniform like I
don't know what do we have uh just a one
ey I guess which will be called
something like whether or not this is
the top essentially so um if the way we
check for this is we say that if I mod 2
equals z then we're at the top right so
we'll set this to one otherwise we'll
set it to
zero simple as that so top let's create
that in our fragment Shader for our
pipes so pipe
um do uh
frag um we'll have a
uniform uh uniform int top Okay so
if top uh
is I don't know zero that means what
that means it's false right so if top is
one what we want to do is just invert
the texture so I don't think we can
actually
set
doy =
1 minus I don't think we can actually do
that like it'll yell at us for modifying
something oh oh no it didn't yell at us
it didn't work though but it didn't yell
at us so what have we done here text.
yal one oh minus texture.
y yay there we go inverted all right
awesome how cool is that and if you
switch it to zero you can really get
some crazy things going where nothing is
correct correctly oriented but there we
go so that's an really easy fix we just
flip the text coordin that's it you
could have flipped the mesh rotated the
mesh that would have
been worse I would say so yeah let's
draw the bird in front of the pipes as
well actually I'm getting a frustrated
by that so we'll go Point
2 all right and now the bird should be
in front of the pipes fantastic there we
go so now all that's missing now is some
Collision uh that starts off I mean we
the other thing is we start off inside
this pipe so let's fix that and then
let's let's fix the pipe generation so
so two things we have to do and we're
actually almost done which is cool I
think I can finish this easily in half
an hour so this will be a 3-hour video
incredibly long but whatever we made a
whole game so whatever from scratch as
well pretty much so let's go to
[Music]
um uh let's go
to uh level is what I'm looking for I've
got too many things open let's close
everything so in
level um let's create some kind of
offset so let's go PR it
int offset equals what should we set it
to how about like half the screen or a
quarter of the screen go a quarter of
the screen so five is a quarter of the
screen cuz 20 is our whole thing across
and this should be a FL I guess um and
we'll go
offset offset Plus on the a so that
should pretty much fix that problem
there we go that's pretty much perfect I
think so oh I'm not liking this oh
probably cuz we're not terminating ch W
or anything so let's go ahead and say
after this we'll just go
glfw uh destroy
window and then
gfw uh quit
or um
end uh is there a there has to be a gfw
qu let me just quickly check the wiki
and whatnot although by by Wiki I really
mean um I terminate I mean the getting
started guide because the getting
started guide is surprising ly useful as
you can pretty much imagine so yeah you
terminate all right anyway
um let's see if that fixes that problem
yeah I think it does okay great so now
that we've done that we need the hard
part which is some I guess math and
trial and error um which is the updating
uh of the pipes
so basically we need to Loop through all
of our
pipes whenever this is called which
won't be all the
time we need to
[Music]
um uh I don't think we do need to
iterate through everything what we do
need to do though is say pipes
index so we'll change index index is our
little index here which we will change
but index mod 10 right because we want
we don't want to exceed the bounds of
the array and index will be much bigger
eventually um new pipe so so we'll
create the same literally the same pipe
I think uh the offset will probably
increment as well um oh no no it won't
because index is there for us so this is
actually probably going to be easier
than I thought it would be because we've
got a pretty good setup
here um and then of course we have to do
the same thing for the Y so plus one
or that so that we don't get crashes and
everything in case we're 11 I don't
think we will though but anyway um we'll
do this uh
offset um let's see so this should be
the same as this I
believe so we're kind of regenerating
them this what's going
on
um yeah looking pretty
good uh except for I
which is just going to have to be
mad all right done um and then of course
we do need to remember to increment
index cuz that's our that's that's what
kind of telling us how far along we are
and whatnot okay good so now that we've
done that
um index oh actually no we even don't I
think this might work we just need to
call update pipes at the right moment
essentially which is going to be
interesting so I think we will call
create every
time oh this is going to be I'm just
going to make a wild gas here and
hopefully it works but it might not
which is why it's interesting so we'll
say if um so minus
scroll just count that I think 250
should be about the first time we need
to do it and minus X scroll is is uh mod
like 100 is
zero and we'll call create and by create
I mean update pipes because create is
our other thing oh it's actually called
create pipes it's even
wrong man let's see what happens we
should probably speed up the
bird oh that's wrong so it's happening
way too quickly
no that's still too quick okay
so X SC minus
minus I'm just
thinking let's
[Music]
um what if we because why is it already
that high that's what I'm wondering we
shouldn't have reached 250 just yet
but we
have which makes me suspicious of
something not sure what though H okay
well I guess we'll just tweak
this oh
almost that'll be too much okay let's
increase this though
so let's make this like
280 this would be much harder actually
except that ruins everything um because
it probably doesn't stop through that so
A that's annoying all right I guess
we'll just have to test it the hard way
okay this tweaking is going to take a
while and that's unfortunately we might
not meet our video when how what are we
2:40 2 minutes 40 seconds according to
my
thing okay that's wrong as well but you
can see we're we're regenerating pipes
basically so they're just happening too
quickly so let's make this like 335
maybe same as the
map all right that's still
too it's almost
right oh hang on now it's right
that's going to stop so
that's there we
go
interesting all
right
[Music]
so that's looking all right
okay
so so that's looking all right so
far um and that's pretty good let's add
a fourth
map just in case I think that'll fix our
issue and then I want to add a bit of
parallaxing in so I'm going to set this
to like 05 so now the pipes move at
different rates to that is as you can
see they actually move a bit
faster um which will probably mean that
we run out of pipe
soon like there so we probably need to
decrease this I want to put it back to
120 and see what that looks
like yeah so now you can see the pipes
are moving at a different speed which is
really cool I really like what that
looks like I think it's cool and in fact
that looks the pipes look like they're
generating
perfectly a new one 20 was a good value
um but yes you can play around with that
and you can make this like one or
something so then the pipes will move
much faster and it'll be very hard and
you can see how like different it is
from this as well which is pretty cool
so play around with that for sure um but
I want to keep it on five cuz everything
looks cool like that cool so there we go
um Flappy Bird that's that's quite hard
actually let's let's do this let's put
this to like 11.5
maybe so that's how kind of difference
here at distance yeah that that's easier
but not by much which is good Collision
time so Collision is going to be um easy
kind of um
so because it's just we're going to
collide the mesh of the we're going to
just Collide the birt against the pipe
so it's going to be pretty easy so it's
going to be bullying simple simple
bullying result if we Collide we're dead
we don't need actual response Collision
response or anything so for each of the
pipes length which uh so there's two
there's 10 pipes course so for the for
the pipes that are currently on the
screen let's just extract a bunch of
values cuz I really want to um it's
really important that you see what it
looks like so first of all bird X that's
our first one our bird X doesn't change
it's zero all the time because the bird
is always in the center so what we
actually need to do is check
um the essentially reverse I guess the
pipes so we need to grab the pipes in a
way to the pipes X kind of so we go
minus X scroll because we want to grab
the reverse of it um because X scroll
gets decreased while this should
increase that way we can get the birds
is what I'm saying um uh because really
what we're comparing is Birds to pipes
so the Y will be the actual y because
the bird does have Y which is not
actually there yet so let's create that
method and I'll return y or should I say
positiony um and then we need width and
height and whatnot so we'll also get the
pipes X at this point though so the
pipes X will be just pipes i.g
X and then this will be the pipes y as
well so we've got the a for the bird and
the pipes great now we need all the
width and widths and Heights or the I
guess second X and Y what a whole lot of
stuff so what we can do is we can
actually get the um the first Bird's X
point I guess by grabbing the bird's X
so this this is going to be the left
bound of the bird it's going to be BX or
bird do of that thing I'm just I'm
splitting this up into as many variables
as possible just so you can see it
clearly okay um BX minus so the size of
the bird right divided by two because we
when we created it we
um we don't have to get size
return
size when we created using size we um
went divid by two so that yeah so that
it goes from negative size divid by two
to positive size divid by two all right
um so when we do go birds. get SI bird.
get
size
um y y so we'll do it for all the bounds
so this will be plus right for the right
right side of the bird and then this
will just be uh minus and plus again um
for the top and bottom bounds right
um
okay
so the pipes X bound is going to be the
pipes X because we didn't do it using
that way um we didn't really do it using
kind of AABB style minus plus whatever B
size two um px1 is going to equal that
plus uh the static width of the pipe and
look the height is going to be the Y is
going to be exactly the same right
except for it's appropriate things
fantastic so there we go all we have to
do now is check these against each other
so if the bird's right side is bigger
than the left side of the pipe right and
the bird's um the bird's left side is
less than the pipe's right side we're
inside the pipe
horizontally
um or at least touching it and
then if this is the case
um then oh well the same for y and I
think using yeah so the reason I've set
it up this way um because this should
technically be like Plus or whatever and
then that should be minus because this
negative is down but I've set it up this
way just to make it so that we can
quickly and easily do this kind of
comparison uh we'll return true
otherwise we'll return false not inside
the for Li though there we go so this
Collision should pretty much be all we
need so you can probably put this down
into just this these are just here just
help you um that's literally it so if we
go ahead and inside
update
we so if there's a collision we'll print
out Collision just to see what is up now
if we run this and we hit Collision good
let's try that one Collision Collision
what what try going through it oh I hit
it
it's too hard okay no Collision there
there was a bit of collision there oh
this is difficult okay that
one okay that looks good y so it is
difficult but there we go no collisions
there all right fantastic so
everything's working in the Collision
department now we actually have to
handle the Collision so we want to play
a bit of
a I like playing an animation where the
bird kind of bounces and then just Falls
okay so what we want to have is I like
having a
um like a
private maybe a private
bullying called
control so we'll set that equal to true
so this is whether or not the players in
control right so if there's a collision
we need to do a bunch of things right we
need to say control is false players
lost control of the play uh players lost
control of the of the bird which means
the bird will just essentially fall so
the other thing we want to do though is
set
um this full thing that I made we'll set
the Delta let's make that public and
let's just call
it this will look pretty cool I think
let's just try and hit something boom Oh
it flew away oh but it went down again
okay so if the Collision happens
um
then so if control is true we don't want
to do mul if control is true and
collision
happens there we go so the bird kind of
bounces up as you can see I like and
then false to its deaths and then that
that's it we probably want to stop
scrolling as well so
[Music]
um if
control um do all that
otherwise
don't
there we
go all right cool stuff
so
um that's looking pretty good what else
that's like it I mean one thing I'm
actually not going to do is add sound or
text because adding text to this would
require like
a h it would require us to make a um
font sheet and probably get that to load
and whatever and I think if you guys
really want that I can make a about
extensions video which will just have a
bunch of other stuff like maybe a menu
and stuff but for now I think that's
pretty good so if we hit space bar again
and we're dead it should probably reset
everything so we'll we'll make it do
that um simply probably by creating a
new level if we're
lazy so what we'll say
is um if it's yeah we'll do that in a
minute uh man this is looking pretty
good and we're on well this did take a
while to be honest I was going to try
and do it in like two and a half hours
but we're already 20 minutes over time
anyway the point is this is looking
pretty good I'm thinking is there
anything else I wanted to do oh there
was a fading at the start um in the
thing I showed you so let's quickly make
a fade Shader this will actually be
different from other ones
there fade. frag
fade. so this fade Shader right this
cool fade Shader is actually going to be
um I'm actually going to just create the
geometry in here cuz I can't be bother
creating a vertex straighted forward um
we don't even need that so what we'll do
this will be very basic so void main um
I'll say const uh V for vertices we'll
make six of them obviously um this will
fill the
screen so what this would be
is
um so we'll have effect for like 1.0
negative
1.0 we'll set up a different projection
for this as well you'll see
so come
on
okay so um first triangle second
triangle will just be negative negative
oh wait no positive negative negative
takes a while to get used to knowing all
these values believe me um but it's all
right if you mentally sketch it out all
work so this will be that like that and
then that'll be like that uh this will
always be negative so this is the it
should be overlaying I'm not sure why it
looks like our near and fire switched
I'm going to investigate the maths
behind our thing I bet I've just screwed
that up that has to be it has to be the
orthographic the M The Matrix for f.
orthographic
method vertex ID so we still need to
send a render call for six of these and
it should be a normal draw raal draw
elements to get this to render but I put
I put this in the fragment Shader whoops
L okay we want this in the vertex
Shader okay so there's our cool stuff um
okay now this is where it's a bit
different we need to fade based on the
time kind of so and we do need actually
to probably enable blending in a minute
but out for
color just pop this into location zero
just to make sure um I mean it should
work but anyway uh then we'll just we'll
probably take in a
uniform float
time so if time is greater than 1.0 we
can discard and we can just forget about
rendering completely now otherwise
though color is going to equal VC 4 so
it's going to be white in the RGB but
this will be 1.0 minus time so as time
increases after hits one we will it'll
it'll be gone so it starts at one and
then the the opacity just decreases
until it hits zero because after zero
get discarded fantastic so now that
we've done that um we need to set up two
things in vertex
array we need a way to
draw public vertex
array in count this.
count equals
count so over here
in
um bind we only bind so if IBO doesn't
equal if IBO is greater than zero
because it could be negative one I guess
uh we'll do that um same
here and in draw if IBO is greater than
zero we'll draw elements otherwise we
will call
draw
arrays mode GL
triangles
[Music]
um let's see first uh zero count
count all right um and then we'll I
guess
we'll we'll generate a Vertex array I
don't actually think we need to but
we'll we'll do it um okay great great so
we should have that now we need to set
up the
whole fading stuff as well um and my
fading stuff I okay first thing I'm
actually going to do to be honest before
I do anything is fix my
maths orthographic let's take a look at
you once more
so
[Music]
um that does look
right far minus near that is that is
correct near
far near minus far that's all
right
H
suspicious that should be
correct but yet something but yet it's
inverted kind of near
far
H oh I probably just set them I probably
just set them the wrong
way no I don't think I
did ah weird okay it doesn't matter
we'll um deal with that later so let's D
let's duplicate this obviously and
create it
for our fade Shader we got a lot of
shaders we don't need the text for it of
course
um and oh except the pro Matrix of fade
will be different which you'll see in a
minute
so
fade fade fade all right so the Matrix
for fade is going to
be
um a touch different let me just think
about what I want to set it
to
um probably negative like we I mean we
set the uh where are we we set this from
negative 1 to one and yeah so it's just
going to be negative 1 to one
essentially right so we'll go Matrix 4f
Dot graphic
[Music]
one
one 1
1 1
1 that should be fantastic so in here uh
let's create a background
fade fade will
be a new vertex
array
six put it up here um we
will fade.
render we need a
Time private float time equals
z um in
update time plus equals like 0.1
something low that might be too much
that might be too quick actually 0.0
one um fade. render and then we have to
supply it Shader do Fade do we'll we'll
enable it first of
all and then we'll
say uh Shader do. set uniform
1f
time value is time all right let me just
double check that
Shader yep that's good let's just see
what this looks like so white and then
should disappear Okay cool so we want it
to blend and it couldn't find PR
Matrix oh we don't need a projection
Matrix if where um my bad we don't need
a pro projection Matrix if it's cuz
that's the default projection Matrix so
there we go fantastic so blending we
need to enable blending in open G
otherwise it won't actually blend as you
can see the alpha doesn't actually
matter it will yeah it won't blend on
like semi opaque things basically or
semi-transparent things so when would
doing this what we need to do is we need
to basically uh do a few things first of
all we need to enable G blend now that
by itself probably won't work nope but
we need to we need to specify
essentially the uh the blend function
that we're using
okay so GL Source Alpha and gl1 minus uh
Source
Alpha
will there we go give us a fantastically
nice fade in as you can see awesome
looks pretty good to
me um and it we're straight in the
action as well which is cool so there we
go you don't have to use that but I
thought it would be a cool kind of
blingy thing we'll add all right finally
we're down to the last thing we need to
do and that is optional but cool okay we
want to add
lighting so how we going to do that
let's add it to the background first
because I think that'll be the biggest
kind of thing okay so the first thing we
want is um we want it to probably be
based on the position of the bird I
would say so let's just say the lighting
follows the bird so to do that first
thing we'll do is um in our background
essentially what I want to do is um in
our background vertex and fragment
shaders so in the vertex Shader we want
to take in we need to take in the
current position of the actual
background okay so but but not inclusive
of of the projection Matrix right so if
we grab the view um Matrix and whatnot
and go V 3
position we want to take we want to grab
uh VSS out. position
equals uh
V
3 that times that and if we put in
Constructor just trim off the fourth
component which we don't care about um
and then here if we go V three uh
position we will um basically light it
based on the position and also the bird
so we need to take in a bird we need to
take in a bird
2015 um but seriously we need taking a
bird okay so this bird um we'll get from
our other thing uh we're going to say
that color times
equals like three ID the length so the
the difference between these vectors um
bird minus
FSN
position we're really interested in XY I
think plus like 2.5 and we'll set it to
about I
think that that'll be that'll be cool so
we will have to set a minimum here
otherwise we'll it'll be totally black
if it's too far away which actually will
look pretty cool and demonstrate our
Point perfectly so I am going to show
you that in a minute but um there's our
V 2 so that's why I made V 2 in Shader
the c v it was for the
bird okay okay
so back in
um level when we enable this
Shader what we want to do when we B when
we bind the background is actually
set uniform
2f name bird XY bird
dot okay so the bird's X is just going
to be zero as far as the background's
concerned and the Y will be bir do
y all right magical so um if we were to
test R
this we would see that wherever the bird
is the
background um okay so what's cool is it
actually goes to gray instead of black
which is very cool and I of course do
that on purpose but I like that okay
cool so I can't even get past the first
one I'm terrible at this um what I will
do is I I will add about 0.3 or so and
what that will do is just make sure that
you can see we can still see the texture
at the end yeah if we go too far away it
will still Fade Out to gray okay but it
won't look too bad so one thing we
should do is set our clear color to
probably zero if we get rid of this
it'll just do that as well so that'll
that what that'll do is it'll make it
black instead of gray yeah because our
click hole was white before and also our
pipes don't have lighting which looks
weird but you can see that that looks
pretty cool I kind of like that so yeah
you can keep it gray or whatever if you
want oh and we can actually still we can
actually still play if we hit this we we
can still
bounce we should get rid of that so to
quickly get rid of that um in
bird we will say are we hitting 3 hours
yet my God my goodness we've hit three
hours um if keyboard
and
control so now once we die we're dead oh
controllers in the other thing um that
is
annoying
um I don't even know what to do with
that okay we'll just leave it as is I
think that looks really nice I like that
lighting so let's make it apply for um
pipes as well
so for our pipe
um we'll go into
background we'll copy bird and stuff so
let's paste bird
in uh let's paste in
position and we're going to have a very
similar color
thing now we want to do this after we
potentially discard it otherwise of
course the alpha will probably change
and then then we won't we should we yeah
I might even go higher or whatever it
might be modified we don't we want to
discard it first and then only do it to
the pixels that we don't discard um cool
so we also want to change the vertex
Shader to include this so pipe.
vert V 3
position all right and back in
level we want
to
um uh this shadow. B
when we render the
pipes we want
to do that that's it let's test that out
cool so now the pipes have lighting as
well this is kind of a scary and you can
see the alpha by the way is it's the
pipes are kind of transparent which is
interesting so uh we do not want it to
affect the alpha Channel at all um so to
do that or to not affect the alpha
Channel we can just simply just apply it
to
everything else so what you could do in
fact the possibly the simplest way of
doing this would be simply to just
set color. W equal to
1 um and that would make sure that they
wouldn't be transparent and you can see
that they'll kind of go all dark and
stuff they are actually a bit bright so
I might set this to like 0.1 or
something you can tweak these this is
why I created different shaders no
they're a
bit
no that's not bright
enough is the bird being set
properly
um
interesting cuz they're not being
lit at all actually those
pipes huh maybe I'm not setting the
position but I
am oh this should be model Matrix time
oh there we
go okay so now we go and see you can see
the pipes are being lead now right so
there we go so this is probably better
now okay so now let's bring this back to
like
two this man this game is furiously hard
I'm I'm never going to play my game
anymore because this is just what have I
created um let's set this a bit High
higher so like 12.5 this is for like
noobs like me who need it to be easier
for development purposes of course so
there we go so this is like a kind of
Halloween freaky Flappy Bird thing if
you wanted to make it more subtle right
you can just increase this so if I put
that to like 4 and I put this to
like4 as well that'll be the
minimum you can see it's it's bright
everything's like a bit brighter
including the bird so we can probably
fix that a bit by
tweaking
[Music]
um this if we put this to like one for
the background say we'll get a much more
subtle effect as you can see that's
possibly too subtle two maybe anyway
have fun tweaking the lighting cuz it is
a lot of fun and we can probably bring
this up even
more there we go so that's much more
subtle now I actually kind of like that
um the pipes look like they're being
over lit as well
so one maybe that'll be probably two
how's that lighting that lighting
basically
non-existent
two I actually think the distance could
probably use less
modification in this case there we go so
we get a bit of like specular kind of
off it all right that's looking good
um everything is a bit dark though so
maybe 6
and 7even or
something there we
go awesome Okay so we've got a bit of
lighting and Flappy Bird now it's
looking pretty good
um yeah that's I mean we're pretty much
done um the only thing I don't like and
literally the only thing I'm going to
fix at this point is the fact that we
can still flap after we kind of died and
also want to reset everything so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to say
instead of making it so the bird can't
flap if um so level will have a
uh public balloon game
over
return uh
control equals false is game over I
always game over is game over so uh what
we'll do is we'll say um this will be
interesting but in update
if game if is game over level equals new
level pretty crazy and would be probably
responsible if this was multi-threaded
or something but I think this will work
out
fine so okay that's not good so uh
no uh so
control
reset equals false so um
basically what I'll do is I'll say
if no control
and uh input. is key down G left W key
space then reset equals
true
um
let me just import that
statically import static or.
wgfw
gfw star fantastic there we go so now um
we have we hit reset true and then this
will be not control and reset so
essentially we could just return
reset so now if we cly we're good and
then if we hit space for again we're
where we
start so play around with the lighting
it's probably not perfect you could
probably tweak it a bit but there you go
you got Flappy Bird and you can play it
as many times as you want and you can
cry um so I would probably set it if I
was this is was it's like totally
production release or whatever um I'll
probably Set uh I probably add some
lighting to the bird or something as
well but I'll probably set um this to
about 11.5 I think instead 12.5 cuz 12.5
is easy even though I'm failing it you
can play around with the yeah see that's
that that's the infuriating level that
you're used to in also this is a bit
easier cuz you can actually hold space
bar so you can make it so that you can't
hold space bar um that would be uh
infuriating but yeah so you can do
whatever you want really um but yeah up
to you anyway um I like how fade plays
again as well that's nice everything
gets reset cool so any questions leave
them in the comments below um make sure
you follow me on Twitter twitter.com
thej so you don't miss anything uh I
stream pretty regularly on twitch.tv
thej so you can always catch me there as
well and if you want to know if I'm
streaming just follow me on Twitter
you'll see and please hit the like
button if you guys enjoy this video cuz
it is 3 13 minutes long right now and
it's just massive all of this code in in
its current state in its current non
non-perfect State uh I mean it's pretty
good I think will be pushed to GitHub as
soon as I finish recording this so in
other words it will be um over
at uh you'll you can find well there'll
be a link in the description first of
all but you can find it over here under
a repository which will be called FL uh
just Flappy it'll just be called Flappy
okay so feel free to look at the code
there and um hope you guys learned
something and as I said please don't
forget to to hit the like button if this
video uh was enjoyed by yourself or if
you got something out of it I hope you
did um again any questions leave them in
the comments I'll try and actively
answer those comments
[Music]
um uh let's quickly handle this stuff
before
I so we'll just push
um whoops I don't know what I did
there um so we'll do that
[Music]
um and then could not create could not
create window G window all right and
that's pretty much it no more to do I
hope um there shouldn't be all right
cool so any other yeah questions leave
in the comments below hope you guys
enjoy this and I will see you next time
goodbye